man it's like uh all the news in the
world got dumped today it's crazy we got
uh news in the Trump Camp Trump's going
to be turning himself uh turning himself
in next week so that's uh that's fairly
crazy we got uh the Tate Bros have been
released which is pretty crazy I think
that's a good news considering they
haven't been charged with a crime at
least that's the latest I don't know if
they have been lately but I'm last I
heard they were not even charged with
crimes and then uh that dude Mackie who
made a meme got convicted so it's just a
very it's a very crazy day plus you've
got these tornadoes hitting in the South
so you know condolences to everybody
hope everybody's safe and uh what we're
going to be doing today is we're gonna
have uh Donald Trump Jr's gonna be
calling in to talk about the indictment
against his father so I'm not going to
waste any time let's jump right into our
sponsor for tonight ladies and gentlemen
this show is brought to you by
castbrew.com if you would like coffee
whose mascot is a rooster and you would
like a coffee coffee blend called rise
with Roberto Jr a light roast for
breakfast well then you got to go to
castbrew.com and purchase our Casper
coffee it is certified USDA organic we
also have a very robust dark blend
called Appalachian nights and available
right now we also have a Colombian and
French roast and guess what this is our
company we own it we're sponsoring
ourselves if you guys want to support
the show you can buy coffee it's a
pre-order we'll Ship by the fifth and uh
we've already sold over twenty thousand
dollars worth of coffee product with
only four options so far we're building
it out we're hoping to have four
signature Blends a seasonal blend and
this is going to help kick off the
coffee shop that we are currently
building out right now and then we're
gonna try and create a whole bunch of
these all across the country where we
can create a communal space so
castbrew.com buy our coffee and also
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our work because as a member
you get access to uncensored members
only shows Monday through Thursday as
well as our Discord server where you can
hang out with people networks start
companies whatever it is you guys want
to do we're doing a new cool thing
starting probably next week or maybe the
next two weeks Friday's sponsorships
will be reserved for our members this
was brought up by a member in our
call-in segment and he said how about
your members are your sponsors why don't
you shout out your members who have
companies or projects I said that is
brilliant so already a really great idea
from a member so we're going to try and
set up a system whereby y'all who are
members can decide who has the cool
project that we should promote and then
Friday night the show will be brought to
you by that member who has that company
I think it's a brilliant idea and I'm
really excited to do it so become a
member if you want to be involved in the
community stuff that we're building and
all of that the physical location the
clubs and everything like that smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and more is Alex bruceowitz
thanks for having me Tim it's great to
be here with you fine gentlemen on this
Friday evening uh but I'm Alex bruzowitz
I'm a political consultant I work with a
lot of the most pro-trump and mega
members and we like to have a lot of fun
we like to piss a lot of people off and
I got to move over real quick but there
you go yeah we pissed a lot of people
off on Twitter and hopefully some of my
haters and the losers are tuning in
tonight because there's a lot to discuss
but uh it's great to be here on this
Friday with you fine gentlemen right on
we got a lot of hanging out as well hey
what's up everybody my name is alad
aliyahu I'm a journalist over at timcast
news Tim thanks for having me on
absolutely Phil Labonte hello I am
philibonti lead singer of All That
Remains anti-communist
counter-revolutionary I'm Ian Crossing
what's up dudes also we'll mention
Twitter open sourced a bunch of code
today the first step on a long journey
of Awesomeness and that's another thing
I forgot about that too there's so much
news in the code there were identifiers
if you were a Democrat a republican a
VIP or Elon Musk Elon was like it's
going to be embarrassing this is the
road which one do you think they gave
preference treatment too I have yeah
right elander let's find out the reason
they created the qualifiers in the first
place was to be like don't block these
people block those people we also have
Mr Kellen that's right uh Elon freed the
code on my birthday for me for me he
told us happy birthday happy birthday
so let's just jump right into this first
story says from The Washington Post
Trump plans to turn himself in for
arraignment Tuesday reports The
Washington Post I mean that's basically
it they say uh former president Trump
plans to fly to uh from Florida to New
York on Monday before appearing in a
specially secured Manhattan Courthouse
to be arraigned on still unspecified
criminal charges people briefed on the
arraignment said Trump is not going to
Hole up in Mar-A-Lago his lawyer Joe
takapina said Friday a day after news of
the Manhattan Grand jury's indictment
broke so I guess I guess the question
here is how do they even do this like
he's gonna have to be released on bail
on his own recognizant so they're not
going to put him in jail what is Secret
Service trying to go in jail with him
well it's going to be it's never
happened in the history of our country
in our 250 years as a republic this has
never happened before but from my
understanding Secret Service is taking
lead on uh this process so they've been
working with uh the NYPD uh and so on
Tuesday he's going to be arraigned and
uh I don't know what that's going to
look like but uh it's it's terrible this
is happening happening in our country
it's his third world crap this is a
Banana Republic now
um but I gotta say they're going to
regret that putting that guy on a mug
shot can you imagine the t-shirts that
are coming from that one of the stories
we'll get to later is um
how Joe Biden is going to spend the rest
of his days with Hunter Behind Bars
because they set the precedent but
you've also got that Mackey guy who made
a meme in 2016 he just got convicted
formally by uh I think it was a jury
right and there's a woman who did the
same thing he did and she got no charges
and what he did was he made a meme that
said text instead of going to vote text
your vote to this number which was a
false thing and so they're like hey you
can't maybe find a single victim and
then but the girl did the exact same
thing hey instead of voting for Trump
and don't wait in long lines text this
number with your vote and texts are
totally she didn't post a number though
but she did say text voting is
legitimate so I'm saying we're already
in it we are absolutely in it 100 and
you know on January 6 all the people
that brought a trump flag to the Capitol
and peacefully protested they're
spending years and years behind bars but
uh just a couple of days ago
transurrectionist storm state capitals
across the country and uh they're never
going to see a day in jail and not only
that but they attacked cops there's
videos of them pushing and fighting with
cops and there was a shaman although
I'll back those guys those guys up on
the rights I'm saying guys for men and
women and everybody everybody's guys in
my opinion that's how I talk but like it
didn't seem VI I wouldn't call it Violet
when the politicians came into the this
is in Tennessee the one I saw uh the
cops grab people to move them out of the
way there's a little pushing and pulling
I didn't see any blood I didn't see
anyone striking anyone so I support your
right to protest I didn't see any police
throwing flashbags into the crowds or
tear gassing these innocence it's not
just about that it's about the
protesters were holding up seven fingers
as a protest sign which signifies that
the perpetrator of the mass shooting was
a victim
that like you are in a cold Civil War
and I don't even know if it's fair to
call it cold because the power of the
federal government is being wielded to
beat people on the right into submission
it is it is the weight of of executive
Authority crushing down on people so I
don't think it's I don't think it's fair
to call it cold I think we have seen
physical confrontations we have seen
death we saw the far left try to to burn
down the White House burn down St John's
Church and we saw even with January 6
the fighting on one side like the
conflict is hot it's happening it's just
not like people are people are so
ignorant to history of the world they
expect there to be a formal declaration
by Virginia we're here by declare how we
are Declan Civil War and then for New
York to be like we are mobilizing our
troops to fight you and then they March
down the street towards each other what
do they think war is I don't know I
think Jack some jack besubik sum this
week up pretty pretty well he said this
week they indicted their top political
opponent convicted a descendant and one
one of their nuts shot up a school full
of Christian children and that's just
one week and it's such a that's what's
happening I mean they threw a guy
they're trying to put a guy who made a
meme mocking Hillary Clinton and believe
me there's a lot of material there to
mock her with but they they're throwing
this guy in prison they're trying to
throw him in prison for making a
freaking Meme and and every single
person needs to be speaking out in
defense of Douglas Mackey every
journalist I saw some journalists that
were giddy about this guy being indicted
these are the people that are supposed
to protect the First Amendment and care
about issues like this but they're
celebrating a guy who mocked a political
figure for going and they wanted to go
to jail what's what's the legality if I
stood outside of like a voting place and
told it's shut down today guys go home
the legality doesn't matter obviously
and clearly well what he did was tell
them instead of don't go vote instead
just texting it doesn't matter because
anyone he posted a meme to like nobody
on the internet so what is a legality
can I stand outside of a voting station
and tell people it's closed today
everyone goes
absolutely just make sure you register
as a Democrat before I mean I'm being
serious is it legal or illegal to do you
cannot go to an individual and and lie
to them to trick them into not vote okay
that's my question and that's what this
person you're right he didn't go to an
individual and there were no victims
okay and there was a woman who was a
Democrat who did the exact same thing
who wasn't charged so um I don't want
I'm not interested in hearing any
arguments about it he's going to the
jail for election interference right you
want to talk about election interference
the left is concerned about election
interference if they want to throw a
MIMA in jail but they're celebrating
corrupt and obese Alvin Bragg for
throwing the top you know trying to
throw the top political opponent in jail
that's election interference if we're
talking about election interference not
some guy who made a meme that barely
anybody saw and so these people are sick
uh and they try them in Brooklyn right
no conservative is going to get a fair
Shake in Brooklyn no concern is going to
get a fair Shake in D.C and they're
going to convict him it's terrible
that's what's happening and then they're
gonna and they're gonna push for jail
time because they're saying it's 34
counts they're gonna move for like they
are going to try to put him the reason
they're doing it at the state level is
because he can still run for president
he can still win the presidency and if
it was a federal crime which the FED
said there's no we can't try him for
this then he'd be able to Pardon himself
but it's a state level crime so they
lock them up they lock them up Alex I
wanted to follow up and ask you about
this there's been interesting reactions
um to this indictment across the
political Spectrum one from Governor Ron
DeSantis whose tweet reads the
weaponization of legal uh the legal
system to advance a political agenda
turns the rule of law on its head it is
Un-American he says the Sorrows back
Manhattan D.A has consistently bent the
law to downgrade felonies and to excuse
criminal conduct yet now he is
stretching the law to Target a political
opponent and then most interestingly at
the end of his tweet he says Florida
will not assist in the extradition in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
thesaurus backed Manhattan prosecutor
and his political agenda can I get your
reaction to this yeah so that second
part we'll start with the second part
that's that's a not even an issue like
that's not even a part of the discussion
and that's just him trying to get some
attention out of this uh you know this
stuff for for his own political game but
the first part of it it his strong
statement came after uh you know 48
hours
of you know attacks like because when it
first was reported he was completely
silent and then when he finally opened
his mouth about it that Monday his
Consultants had him read this script to
at a press conference and a planted
question
and he says that it's a sideshow he said
he's not going to be distracted by a
circus he said he's focused on Florida
then he traveled to whatever state to
sell his book but he only responded
because he had so much outside pressure
and he had you know it was terrible for
him in the polls he started going down
in the polls after do you think that
response second part is bait whereas he
says Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances that issue
with the sorospact Manhattan prosecutor
and his again I think that is simply
just him trying to save face and try to
get some publicity for himself out of
this movement that there's not even been
a conversation about that and he had a
lot of the DeSantis uh influencers who
don't influence much that were pushing a
narrative about how you know descent if
Trump really wants to fight the
political persecution he should take a
stand and listen to DeSantis and and
refuse to be extradited and I think
that's just so foolish the Soros DA's
are it's popular to attack them nowadays
he's mentioned Soros twice in this tweet
any thoughts on that yeah I'm no fan of
Soros and Soros waited on the 2024
election he said that he believes Ron
DeSantis will be the nominee and will
cause Trump to go into some uh
narcissistic induced state so you know
Soros is a is a guy that we have to pay
attention to and do something about I
don't think that a foreign-born
individual should be able to pay for
State prosecutors and have them do the
bidding of the political party that he
wants what's a is he's paying companies
to pay the pros to get the prosecutors
packs that's how you have non-profits an
individual can't just pay
a million dollars to a candidate so what
he does is there there are a variety of
super Pacs and packs political action uh
committees political action committee
yes he can give as much money as he
wants to them and then they campaign on
your behalf the Only Rule for super Pacs
is that they don't collude with the
candidate it's like a free speech ruling
which is just crazy because it's a
secondary Campaign which of course you
can do everything get you elected and
you can funnel as much money as you want
into them they're not supposed to
collude but they do with the wicked and
odd yeah but I mean Soros plays every
game he doesn't just focus on the the
national politics he's at the state
levels he's at the local levels and
that's why conservatives and and people
who care about our country need to be
paying attention to every single race
and so there's a race that every
American needs to be paying attention
about right now it's the Wisconsin
Supreme Court race uh where a guy named
justice uh Dan Kelly is running for the
Supreme Court there uh Scott Pressler
give him a shot he's been doing really
great work on the ground in Wisconsin
turning out the vote uh but we you know
we need that Wisconsin Supreme Court
case uh sorry Wisconsin Supreme Court
see uh pretty badly because if we don't
get it we're going to fall into another
Soros uh judge Soros gave a million
dollars to help this Democrat get
elected to the Supreme Court uh in
Wisconsin so he's focused at every level
of government and we're seeing the
consequences of that right now where
conservative billionaires are uh you
know not so focused on anything except
for again Ron DeSantis uh enough money
to try to beat Trump in the mega
movement you know it's very concerning
that if anyone even an American can can
give just push buttons and send hundreds
of millions of dollars to other people
to go do political work for them like
that's like a hijacking of our politics
system we're supposed to be for the
people no no no no no no no no no no you
can you can use your resources to
promote ideas that you want to see
spread around anything any any kind of
limit on that is a limit on the freedom
of speech because you have the right
right to hire people and engage in
Commerce and engage in activity in
society this is this is Citizens United
that's the argument that's made the the
argument with the Supreme Court found
that citizens united or in the citizens
united case was that you had the right
to have an organization to promote your
ideas that your property as in your
money you could use your property to
promote your ideas and that's what
citizens united is so if you want to
start a foundation or or something like
that and you want to go ahead and have
some kind of organization that promotes
ideas that's the Heritage Foundation
that's Cato that's the center for
American progress It's all kinds of
things yes it matters yeah that's that's
yeah it's totally media
I mean and and I I absolutely detest
like what Media Matters is trying to
promote right absolutely they're
communist they're awful I think and I
think that if they got their way they
would literally destroy the United
States I think that's their intent they
are ill-liberal authoritarians but it
doesn't mean that we can say well shut
them down you can't do that I'm not in a
not in a free country I have a personal
problem with citizens united I don't
like it I don't like that you can put
unlimited amounts of money into politics
and in the beginning of the Republic you
couldn't stop it what do you mean you
could you always could no it was when
someone was like taking Whistle Stop
dreams like why can't I spend my own
money campaigning for myself I'm like
well he's got a point and then other
people would do the same thing the
newspapers would be like we endorse this
person and we're going to put all of our
resources to getting them elected we're
going to put them on the front page it
was it's never been any different there
was a challenge to a Citizens United and
Supreme Court was like it's your dollar
you you can speak and also another thing
that I want to point out like you hear
Democrats that have a lot of problem
with citizens united they're always the
ones that complain about it and since
citizens united you've had Barack Obama
then you had one uh one term of of
Donald Trump and then Joe Biden so it's
not that citizens united means that
conservatives or or May and maybe it
does mean the corporations because the
corporations are in bed with the
Democrats nowadays but it doesn't mean
that it's automatically going to be
conservative ideas or that it's going to
be uh uh the oligarchy of the the the
church being in in charge so far it's
been Democrats well we were talking
about you know Matt Gates before we we
launched the show here but Matt Gates
takes zero dollars from special interest
groups or packs he's was the first
Republican politician to say I don't
want your money yeah Barack Obama spent
more money than anyone ever and then
Hillary Clinton did the same thing and
Donald Trump didn't spend more money
than everyone and he still won you know
so so it makes money what makes me a big
fan of these Mega politicians from
president Trump to Matt Gates is they
would rather have small dollar donations
from hard-working Americans than go and
kiss the asses of the club for gross of
the world who receive you know 200
million dollars from five people and
then they have to take marching orders
president Trump when he ran in 2020 53
of his dollars came from small dollar
very small dollar donors Ron DeSantis on
the flip side right now 95 of his
donations come from 500 people and he
raised 200 million dollars 500 people
gave this guy 200 let's let's address
this right here we got this tweet from
Liz Harrington at realiz USA president
Trump raised over four million dollars
in 24 hours after indictment in Alvin
Bragg Witch Hunt over 25 percent of
donations came from first-time donors to
the Trump campaign and that right there
can I just I just want everyone to to
figuratively gloat over this as I will
now rub it in the face of that Politico
reporter who said Donald Trump will not
earn a single new voter from this
indictment don't overthink it the
indictment is bad for Trump and I'm just
like bro he just he's got new voters
right here literally literally right
here more money pouring in this is what
they asked for I have to wonder if
they're like act if they really do want
Trump to be in office because the media
knows that when he's when he's in office
they make money well I think there's a
stupid narrative that I want to debunk
real quick that was being pushed by a
lot of folks who don't want to see Trump
uh be the Republican nominee they say
the Democrats are indicting Trump and
trying to throw him in jail because they
want him to win now they are trying to
throw him in jail because they're
absolutely terrified that he is going to
win
um but you know I'm glad you put out
those statistics a fourth of the new
donors are first-time Trump donors these
like normal people are watching what's
taking place normal people are watching
Joe Biden throw broke grandmas who
brought Trump Flags to the Capitol in
jail they're watching Joe Biden throw a
guy who made a meme of Hillary Clinton
in jail and now they're going to watch
them throw the Pres you know president
Trump uh be trying to throw him behind
bars or watching this and they think
this is disgusting how could this ever
happen to our country and a lot of folks
who came over here as immigrants from
countries like Cuba or a lot of these
Guatemala they fled corrupt regimes like
this they don't want this to come if
they if this happens the United States
of America there's nowhere else for
anybody to go El Salvador
it means the Savior and that's kind of
funny but up until uh uh naively I think
I think pronouncing it wrong up until
like he got in and started reforming it
especially with Bitcoin there I would
have said no other country and I'm kind
of like Salvador's doing pretty well but
but for the most part in terms of the
wealth the access the opportunity El
Salvador's doing fantastic
so it's like okay I like it but let's be
real the United States is like supposed
to be the Bastion of freedom and if it
falter is here having to retreat to the
next best thing is still a loss it's the
loss of of the best absolutely I've got
this feeling
oh holler El Salvador what's happening
boo Kelly uh I I support the presidency
I'm not into like do I support Trump do
I support Biden like look I will work
with anyone that wants to bring Liberty
to the world and but I think all of us
should be supporting the office I got
the individuals I got a problem with
that that that verbiage bring bring
Liberty to the world that sounds a whole
lot like George Bush man no that's
sporting you you can't export liberty no
you know sure you can build free
software that lets people
what if they don't want it yeah but but
come on like also realize if we blow up
all their kids then their kids will be
free from being alive yeah so when I
know George W bush
I'll explain what I literally means
Liberation but I mean that we could
build software that we utilize in the
United States to so that people can
govern themselves locally Liberty
Liberty is Liberty is just like you can
lead a horse to water but you can't make
them drink you cannot make people want
to be free if people want a Theocratic
government they're and you give them
Liberty they're going to give themselves
a Theocratic government but if people
have technology that is muting their
ability to see the real world and then
you give them what do you mean see the
real world like Tick Tock the algorithm
is making them see what the CCP wants
them to see so if we can give them
technology where they can see reality a
little more clearly I mean you don't
choose Liberty do you I don't know if
that's true I I think
when when you give people the ability to
see the world you end up with
I'll just put it this way I think there
was a uh I believe in free speech I
believe in transparency but I do think
it could go either way you give people
absolute freedom and then they might
just become gluttonous there needs to be
moral foundations we agree upon where we
have limits this is why we have borders
I think one of the problems we had as a
country is
too much of the country became Live and
Let Live and there there needs to be two
forces of pushing and pulling where one
group challenges that one group is
holding everything back saying no no we
shouldn't change it the other group says
I hereby challenge you we go to court we
determine okay this was good that was
bad and that's how we progressed
properly but what happened is the the
conservative chain was broken and the
left just zoomed full speed off into I'm
gonna do whatever I want with no
restrictions and now you end up with
child sex changes we need a strong
Republic that's the Restriction force is
the Congress and the Senate you know the
house and honestly the executive branch
has an opportunity to be a stop Gap with
the veto power
um I don't like seeing things rushed
through so I would encourage I think
actually that we are technocracy whether
we want to admit it or not that we've
become a technocratic republic and if we
don't start creating a technocratic
republic like we want to see it it's
going to be created for us in a way that
we don't like Alex I wanted to follow up
with you with something we touched on
that you kind of touched on with this
indictment and it was kind of the
political ramifications for it and what
the Democrats like a cynical Democratic
operative might be trying to pull
together here with um with this
indictment that would make it more
popular among the base but what would
you say to a like a cynical Democrat
operative who might say that Trump might
be more palatable now in a primary
because of this but in a general he
would be less palatable to Suburban
white women than maybe around DeSantis
would against the Joe Biden well new
polling just came out today uh done by
uh the people's pundit Barris I think
he's a really smart guy that had Trump
winning with women 52-19 against Ron
DeSantis you know I took my mom to meet
Trump wow in August at a rally in
Wisconsin and the first thing my mom
says to Trump is
you know Mr President I had a crush on
you in the 80s like there's a lot of
women my mom's age that remember Donald
Trump from the 80s and they loved the
guy when everybody loved the guy when
everybody was allowed to love the guy uh
and president Trump does very well with
you know with the at least
um you know the the pageants he used to
own the pageants and what happened to
the pageants what about with
Independence though that was so the
polls I've been seeing show that random
sentence does better well there's
there's some polls that he does better
there's some polls that he doesn't a lot
of the polls that the DeSantis team
likes to tout her paid for polls a guy
named Chris Wilson with WPA Intel he's
notorious well do you think calls Donald
Trump would be more palatable in a
general election to moderates than uh I
do I think that the a lot of I mean how
many folks in here voted for for Trump
in 2020. Trump I did not vote I would
have Trump you vote for Trump I didn't
vote either no how do you how do you
view the
uh indictment of him and the fact that
they're trying to throw him in jail
well I don't I don't I don't like the
idea I don't like the president of
taking down past past presidents because
then the next president's going to take
down past presence then the one after
that's going to take down the one before
and so Trump just has so much baggage
though relatively the argument widely
though sorry but that's that's good I
appreciate that point and then my I want
to follow up
um would you rather have Rhonda Sanders
or Donald Trump oh I need to I this is
this is why we have two years to
campaign I want to talk to both of them
and have deep conversations about
technology and their Visions for the
future so would you be able to say like
right now based on what you know is
there One Direction you lean towards I
know a lot of Trump's friends like I
know a lot of people that work with them
and forum and but I I don't like when
they're like they'll call him the boss
because the boss is the American people
and we need to serve the office all of
us they do well we've also had a lot of
DeSantis friends on I mean I don't know
what how how do you lean or are you
neutral on the two of them I'm very
neutral I mean does the indictment turn
you off from Trump no no no and I think
that's a sentiment that's across the
country like this real quick I just
think everybody who knows the show and
knows Ian that his input on this is
valuable right Ian's got like a weird
political stance that's not hyper hyper
like
it's not the same as all of us who are
clearly on a track and have views like
feels very libertarian I'm pretty
Centrist you know moderate you're very
conservative Ian's the Wild Card who
often defends Democrats in ways we don't
agree with so I think your inputs it's
very valuable to me right now like you
don't know between the two I think that
says a lot but also the fact that you're
saying that this indictment of him like
doesn't make you reject him and like
you're you're not even thinking about
that I think most people are exhausted
by the that the Democrats have
put the country through for seven years
Witch Hunt after Witch Hunt after Witch
Hunt into president Trump from uh the
moment he came down the escalator the
the Mueller hoax the Ukraine hoax the
um you know uh the January 6th the list
goes on and people are just exhausted
and they're throwing him in jail over a
a personal payment I guess how would you
respond to people who say that he has a
lot more baggage than DeSantis does and
that would turn off wait let me go over
it would be like January 6th
and then not also not pardoning January
six prisoners um I'll just look at the
camera when I say this you just don't
know Rhonda Santos's baggage yet and
believe me there's a lot of material
there and I kind of feel like he's he's
more likely to compromise and I feel
like Trump is more likely to enact
Revenge I mean and I don't mean that I
don't mean that in a biblical sense I
mean it more like a I'm not listening to
you I'm done with you you wasted my time
you're fired whereas the sentence is
going to be like let's try and work
together to make a better it seems like
we're like a tipping over the edge of
the liberal economic order into the New
World Order and we have an opportunity
to unify and create the New World Order
In Like An American Image where we have
like localized government property
rights free speech gun control gun well
gun rights and things like that and and
if we fight and argue as Americans then
it'll be the world economic Forum that
builds it for us and then we'll be all
like still and then we'll be arguing
with them and we'll be all trained to
argue so I really want someone that can
unify and not unify out of fear unify
out of love and like a vision for
reality like a growth pattern well in a
weird way I think on Tuesday our country
is going to be more unified than ever
before even though we're going to seem
so incredibly divided but when there's
the photographs of the former president
of the United States and the leading
opponent to the current president when
they're walking him into a jail
to try to you know book him that's going
to bring people together people don't
understand like he's going into a
holding cell yeah like when he goes in
I'm like typically when you're arrested
you get placed in holding it's not like
a jail where they lock you in to punish
you it's like we're temporarily placing
you here as we process your paperwork
how are they going to do that it's
terrible but they're going to do it but
but a secret service goes in there with
them oh absolutely and they're going to
protect the guys this is great and
that's gonna be on Tuesday but but
absolutely and then you know think about
this the ads that the Suburban women are
going to see of President Trump being
locked in a jail cell while violent
criminals are you know ravaging through
cities burning down cities beating up
cops punching women and Alvin Bragg is
letting you know he he's letting 60 he's
trumping down felonies to 60 of them
he's bumping them down to Mississippi 8
000 people yeah he did the first step
back so isn't it completely ironic
in New York they released 8 000 felons
Trump's Criminal Justice Reform wasn't
like if you're a violent murderer you go
free sometimes
and then people who pled down come on
and they put down a lot of felonies as
well I mean I could pull up the first
step back good so it was it was meant it
was one it's not retroactive
and then two it was mainly targeted
towards non-violent drug offenders Alice
Marie Johnson for example was a
wonderful wonderful woman who I've
gotten to know who uh was sentenced to
almost to life in prison for having just
a little bit of drugs on her in the back
of her car but but even then if the
point were this Trump wanted a Criminal
Justice Reform and Bragg wanted Criminal
Justice Reform and then Bragg says I am
reforming criminal justice and then
Trump says I'm reforming criminal
justice and then Bragg says now I'm
going to indict Donald Trump on BS
charges that are past the statue of
limitations you're like one of these
people is lying yeah or well reforming
it doesn't always mean making it better
you can reform it into something very
horrible I mean how many of you support
the idea that you know people who get
caught with a bag of weed shouldn't go
to jail for 10 years I agree yeah
absolutely I don't think that's what the
first step back was doing and I think
that would be grossly mischaracterizing
that's what the entire purpose of it was
to be about for non-violent drug
offenders who are treated unfairly by a
corrupt justice system who you know led
by Joe Biden and the the you know the
crime bill of the 1990s you know I'm not
sitting here saying we need to let
everybody out of jail but I think
there's certain cases where you look at
and you're like man this person is
treated unfairly and oh we got done all
right let's add let's head down in here
I'm gonna just pull him in the room I'm
assuming he's here so I'm just asking
let's get back to that conversation
do you support the first step back
do you want to let I did okay guys Don
Jr is here what's up Don
um what's happening guys what's going on
welcome to the show I think man can
everybody hear you yeah
you can hear me okay yeah yeah so uh
they indicted you're dead what's
happening
what's happening is uh our country's
devolve far further than we could have
ever possibly imagined I mean uh this is
a third world stuff uh stuff that the
federal government who actually oversees
elections and spent six years trying to
throw my father in prison for it decided
not to pursue but a Soros funded D.A
apparently uh I guess it's you know
following his marching orders and doing
what he's told and you know what they
paid for his election to do
so we we asked Ian Ian's kind of a wild
card when it comes to politics because
he's not he's not in the same space we
are he's he often he says he wants to
pardon people like Hillary Clinton but
he says it's not moving him like you
what you're saying it's like it's not
turning you off from from Trump no it's
not but Dom what's your vision of the
future
listen I need I think you need someone
to go burn it all down yes you know
Trump trump is a lame duck uh is
actually much better than someone that
has to get reelected again and has to
play that game I want someone who will
go in there and literally Burn It To The
Ground because it's going to be that
like
I used to believe guys like you know
even when I got into this I functured
you know real and uh you know I got
there I was like well listen this is
what America is and I I believe this and
I'm a patriot and I'm like oh my God
even you know once I went through what I
went through with Russia Russia Russia
you know 50 hours of testimony and Adam
Schiff up there saying I committed
treason somehow and then I see you know
of course nothing happens with that of
course none of that was actually
accurate it was all a perjury trap
hoping that in 50 hours of testimony
asking me the same you know a thousand
questions maybe I say it a little bit
differently the the 50th time I'm asked
and therefore I committed perjury and
that's how they get you uh but even even
I who sort of had my eyes open during
that were like well there's still
something to it right we all made the
same mistake with with the FBI and what
they tried to do to Michael Flynn it's
like well it's the FBI so there must be
some truth to it right they're not fully
corrupted it's the FBI the CIA same
thing well so let's you know and we're
seeing them go after parents in this
those people are domestic terrorists a
concerned parent going to a PTA meeting
uh but you know some you know trans
shooter can have a Manifesto and kill a
bunch of Christian kids and well that's
not domestic terrorists because they're
Christians like who really gives a
you know that it's it's really scary
where we're at well so so you know let
me ask I want to burn it to the ground
so but when you say that like what's the
what's the Practical step is that uh
what was that policy that your uh that
Trump senior he's gonna fly
when you say that is that what you were
meaning like we're gonna go and we're
going to defund the FBI we're going to
fire all the bureaucrats
yes I mean I mean you got to do as much
as you possibly can you got to get other
people who are willing to go along with
that because I mean I think that's what
you know in 16 we're like Hey we're
coming in from the outside you sort of
assume that you know hey you may have a
little bit differences in policy and
whatever but you know people still want
the best for America and that's just not
even remotely true uh you know these
bureaucrats they wouldn't they wouldn't
succeed in so many other things and
they're going to hold on to what little
power they have because they wouldn't
get it anywhere else uh you see that uh
what's going on you know in our military
and you know the the woke nonsense I'm
like the decision-making process the
withdrawal from Afghanistan uh
everything that's gone I'm like they
couldn't have seen it coming I mean this
I'm like you couldn't have seen it
coming you were there for 20 years what
do you mean you couldn't have seen it
coming like I saw it coming and I don't
know anything about Afghanistan like uh
my nine-year-old son I was picking up
from from school that week and he was
like Hey Dad like why would we leave 86
billion in equipment there I don't
understand dad why would we pull out our
soldiers before the people that have
been helping us for 20 years I like I
was like I felt like an idiot because I
did I was trying to explain to a
nine-year-old that yeah no these people
are just they're that they're that far
gone it's on purpose yeah the word is
surrender that was a surrender in
Afghanistan to the Taliban yes it's and
that should be the word I mean they're
putting up videos of all the equipment
you know they have the second largest
Fleet of Humvees in the world thanks to
us for you know you know in Minor
Details 86 billion that's like 275
dollars per you know man woman and child
in America like oh just that was that's
your contributions in the Taliban who
our secretary of state Anthony blinken
said
uh like on live TV like in a
congressional testimony that he was and
I quote docked and dismayed that the
Taliban did not install a more diverse
and inclusive government like like
really like you're you're shocked like
you may be dismayed I understand that
like but you're shocked after dealing
with them for 20 years after watching
them throw you know homosexuals off of
buildings and put you know journalists
in a cage douse them in gas and light
them on fire like you're shocked that
there wasn't like a trans Coalition in
the new Taliban government like you're
not a serious person if you think that
well you have no business making
decisions for our country I think these
people are they're they're a cult they
live in this obnoxious internet world
that's outside of reality they and and
where they're they're leading us
straight off a cliff you know what
concerns me Don about like the metaphor
of like burn it all down is that when
you do rapid transformation of political
systems uh the solution might not be
like trying to solve one problem might
create a bigger problem like what we did
in Iraq when we dismissed the bath party
we created Isis we put all these
high-level officials on the street and
then they formed their own paramilitary
basically and and I think that our
governments it is evolving we are
becoming a global Community regardless
if we want to do it or we're just going
to put our fingers in our ears and yell
until it happens to us so I I think we
can I think we can bring people together
with like a a vision of Industry you
know graphene I'm not sure how familiar
yeah come on but it's like a
revolutionizing 21st century technology
well let me let me let me redirect this
in a way not to be I'm not trying to be
discretely Ian but I'll put it this I go
off on tangents I don't blame you Tim
what I what I saw uh don with your dad
and the reason I didn't vote for him in
2016 I voted in 2020 for for uh for
Trump senior because the foreign policy
I thought thought was the best I've seen
in my entire life when when he crossed
it crossed the DMZ into North Korea with
no security detail I nearly cried and
I'm like it was it was a tremendous
powerful move where they could have just
snatched up the president United States
but it was a tremendous good faith
effort to try and de-escalate this war
that's been going on for jet for
Generations I saw all of that foreign
policy and I said wow this is amazing
getting our troops out of Syria and they
lied to him and to us and then I saw
well they're packing Somalia by the way
he took off 500 that we had stations out
there and now they put 600 right back in
because in Syria again that's that's no
well that was Somalia but Syria as well
right I mean I had Joe Kent on my
podcast yesterday whose wife died in
Syria as a result of an ISIS attack and
it's like I do this I was like wait a
minute we have people in Syria still
he's like yeah they're back like I'm
like oh my God they did that without us
even knowing and like I do this you know
like I'm I I'm not necessarily a foreign
policy expert but I'm talking politics
day in and day out and until I had I
guess it was Matt Gates on my podcast
like three weeks ago because he
introduced the bill to try to get us out
of that of course that was voted down
because you know the the uni party in DC
you know they need the endless Wars
that's their retirement plan you get the
board the seat on Raytheon and uh you
know that's how they get out of these
things and so it's it's truly scary yeah
the foreign policy thing was everything
and that's why I'm like when I'm
watching uh you know obviously getting
out of the wars and you know the North
Korea stuff was great and big but the
worst was the reaction from the uni
party Trump's doing it all wrong
remember at the time he's doing it all
wrong I go well what have you guys
accomplished in you know 40 years of
dealing with this problem like have you
had even a meeting like with no you
can't meet with them I'm like well how
are you you've been doing it for 40
years you've accomplished exactly
nothing you have no track record to show
any level of success and you're telling
someone else who actually tried changing
up the game that they're doing it all
wrong and turns out they were right but
that's what's what's really scary is you
know while that's a big deal and that
was Obama told my father directly that
you know hey North Korea is the biggest
threat but you know right now the
biggest threat is like you know what's
going on in Russia and Ukraine with an
army that we're fighting a proxy war
against with plenty of bitterness from a
cold war and the mentality that changed
and you know in Eastern European
mentality it's let's just say very
different uh than certainly the
mentality of uh Americans these days and
you get you piss off someone with 6 000
nuclear warheads because we're fighting
a proxy war against them and like they
just want to continue they're going to
see it through to the end I'm like for
what gains yeah well for what now we're
talking about the unit party here and
um you know you kind of hit on it a
little bit earlier but one of the the
critiques that I hear sometimes from
from some folks is that there are bad
hires in the Trump admin and and you
talked about that when when you first
started talking about this a little bit
um but but you know you're new to
politics in 2016. president Trump was
due to politics you guys come from New
York uh and you know the business world
and you know you I probably just assumed
like a lot of us assumed that anybody
that had an r in front of their name was
on our team and they wanted the same
things that we did and uh I think it's
safe to say that seven years later you
guys know that that's very different so
uh do you think when you guys know who
the friends are now
I I said it earlier right it's sort of
that you make that assumption that some
of these people they're doing it for all
the right reasons and they're patriotic
Americans and they're not like you know
DC uh you know is a collection of some
of the worst uh we have to offer as far
as I'm concerned and that's on both
sides that's a that's a uh you know
bipartisan uh deal and uh but you know
again they don't have much going for
them they probably couldn't do a lot in
a lot of these places I've spent plenty
of time with a lot of them and uh you
know you wouldn't hire them to be you
know a basic guy in business and yet
they have a level of power uh and the
money that comes with that and that and
they ain't letting it go you know the
swamp has a lot of teeth and you you
come in as an outsider you're like okay
like of course these guys want what's
right for America well you know this
week we can buy a little bit of that off
this is the crazy thing it's just so
different than you think so I think you
know now you have an understanding of
that and you just gotta you gotta go in
with that understanding it's so
different uh and again you know we were
he was effective meeting my father
at so many things whether it's
economically foreign policy wise or
otherwise and that's with both sides
working against him uh I mean how many
Republicans you know Paul Ryan like we
we're not right we can't we're not going
to build the wall you know I can't fund
that I want to you know my wife's an art
and liberal and uh she you know she
wants to still be invited to the cool
person holiday party so we didn't have
three billion dollars to finish the wall
but we have 130 for Ukraine to protect
uh you know one of the most corrupt
countries in the world meaning Ukraine
ranked worse than Russia in many
instances uh we have 130 billion dollars
to protect their border it's it's Lunas
the crazy thing is I'm asking when I was
at Occupy Wall Street and even before
that with the anti-war movement when you
said a moment ago the Raytheon
retirement package I'm like that that
right there was such a big issue for all
of the left 12 years ago I'm like where
are they now to just be like hey we've
got a handful of Victories with Donald
Trump we should take those over the
corrupt uniparty Joe Biden instead it's
like their brains melted and they're
just like I'll vote blue no matter who
even if it means more war and now on the
brink of World War III with Ukraine it's
like the anti-war movement turns to Mush
they're scared they're very serious yeah
and that and that's not a never-ending
War I mean that's like a perhaps a
world-ending war yeah yeah right you
know we could get bogged out in the
Middle East forever it's you know maybe
there's some terrorist attacks I'm not
I'm not belittling that or but like
you know those guys wouldn't have the
ability to literally end the world
Russia has 6 000 nuclear warheads like
think about that for a second and you
think that a a
megalomaniac like a Putin and again I'm
not apologizing for him when I when I
don't want to be in these things but
like you don't think a guy like that who
many are saying well he's he's very sick
and he's like you think that guys could
allow Ukraine and actor zielinski to
embarrass him on a world stage without
escalating like no way agreed yeah when
you asked earlier you asked earlier Don
what is it for why are we spending
hundreds or over 100 billion for to
fight a proxy war against uh I think
it's because the the people that are
running the liberal economic order want
to position it above Russia in the New
World Order and they think that stopping
Russia from Gaining economic prowess
with that black seaport access and
Sebastopol will will win us the
greatness in the New World Order and
then we'll decide the rules but what's
happening is it's pushing Russia and
China together exactly the opposite I
mean you know we were going gonna shut
down their currency and meanwhile it's
skyrocketing uh you know we stop our oil
production become dependent on Iran and
Venezuela we didn't recognize and the
world's leading State sponsor of Terror
and like we're begging them for oil
because we shut it down while Russia
continues to pump like it's lunacy the
way to hurt Russia would be for us to
produce more of our own oil Drive the
price of oil down create jobs in America
and like they got nothing else like we
have more than them but you know well
we're not going to do it environmentally
sound you think the Russians you think
they take any environmental precautions
they could care less yeah I think and
China in order to help the United States
like less about hurting Russia more
about helping the United States is is
trade with Russia and it would help us
so much more than it would help them
because of our ability to create here
that it would actually be better and it
would position us and this is what Trump
was basically talking about he sounds
like Trump right I know I think
diplomacy is the answer the Chinese the
Russia Americans need to work together
to protect this planet listen to what
Donald Trump what was the only works
guys if if there's like some force
behind it right that's why Trump they
saw Trump like okay he's not someone to
be trifled with it's the nature of
predation okay Putin is a bully he is a
bully you know even though they're
they're bullies
bullies take advantage of weakness
that's the nature of that game just like
an animal in the wild takes out the
weakest in the herd when they want Phil
Biden on a world stage they're like oh
like we can eat those guys lunch because
it's incompetent you know while Putin is
meeting with a G and while his G is
simultaneously meeting with the Saudis
to get rid of the Petro dollar which
allows the left to have you know the
billions of dollars that they use to
fund trans programs in Pakistan which is
just being stolen by you know people
over there creating an oligarch class
but while that's going on the White
House is hosting the you know the cast
of Ted lasso
shout out to Brandon no it sounds funny
it'd be funny if it was a sitcom but
like man I wake up on some days I'm like
dude I I hope that I'm just like the
star of The Truman Show and that
everyone is just with me because
if they're not it's a disaster hey Don I
know Trump has a long list of
accomplishments I wanted to ask you what
do you think his biggest accomplishment
was and then on the flip side his
biggest shortcoming in his first term
oh
biggest accomplishment I mean I guess it
just look at the the economy was going
so good man you know I guess I I look at
that you know I'm sort of a you know I
was a blue collar guy sort of Trapped in
New York but I spent all my weekends
with guys up in Northern you know
northeast PA and I I shot competitively
hung out with regular guys and like
watching what those guys that continue
to come up to me is like man we had it
so good under your dad like that meant
more to me I mean I think obviously the
North Korea stuff when I was just baller
uh I think the Abraham Accords like that
was the Holy Grail of geopolitical
politics right yes like No One's Gonna
Get a peace deal in the Middle East
we've been trying for centuries it's
like well we got five
it was the Holy Grail of geopolitan it
can't be done it can't be well no it
can't be done by you because you're an
imbecile like you're there you're in
power because you were a big donor to
someone not because you've done anything
relative to this you're there because
you're you've been there longer and you
have seniority it's like
ouchy does anyone really believe that
you was the best guy in medicine that he
should be making the decision no but he
was the best bureaucrat and I'm sure as
he was really good at snaking
anyone who got in the way of him in a TV
Camera from the 80s through because it
doesn't seem like he got anything right
so he may have got some of the things of
covid right in his emails to his
colleagues but that was exactly the
opposite of what he was saying on
national TV because as long as you were
going against Trump you got an extra
camera in your face you got the cover of
Vanity Fair or some you know nonsense
Rag and like that was his currency so so
what do you think Trump's uh as to
re-asked what shortcoming of Donald I I
would I would say you know it has to be
you know on that hiring front because
when you come in as a new from outside
of that world you it takes a lot like
it's hard to overcome Decades of being
like no like if you're gonna do this and
you're you're a public servant you're
doing it for the right reasons and man
it is so wrong it's like what you see in
Paul politics like some of these people
that are running it's like they have no
chance like oh you know what it is it's
a book tour absolutely they're running
so they can drum up some numbers for a
book tour or some guys are running
because the consultant class that we
won't hire needs to have a job and they
got to make their eight or nine figures
taking 20 of the ad by of someone's
campaign and like they're pushing people
like they're being forced into it
because the consultant class is like Hey
listen if you guys don't do it we're
gonna have to you know just get by with
a congressional race and we're not going
to make 15 million dollars this like on
the ad buy like yeah it's a screwed up
place man and like people don't fully
understand that I again I dealt at a
pretty high level and I didn't fully
understand it and I certainly didn't
understand how how deep and depraved it
actually is until you know I mean man
every day my eyes are further opened and
you know this this week this week was
sort of the culmination of all of that
right you saw the the the reaction uh to
the to the shooting in Nashville that
and you know it's like you have moments
in your life I guess where it's just
like a a kick to the groin uh you know
the Afghan withdrawal the week after
that to me as an American was one of
those just you just felt embarrassed
absolutely and at one follow-up on his
greatest response to Nashville was like
that to me which is like you know it's
not it's not the Christian children
they're not the victim it's the trans
community and it's literally going
through a genocide I'm like well like
how like I know you say that but like
where like I I don't see that like it's
I'm a pretty big voice in the
conservative movement and like I have
trans friends and I don't care I draw
the line you wanting to jack up a
three-year-old with hormones without
their parents uh any involvement I think
that's sociopathy but like
I don't know I think I'm pretty you know
let's call it Progressive on the issue
but that's not enough and that one
follow-up on his greatest achievement
situation and that's like everything
else going on right now absolutely and I
had one follow-up on his greatest
achievements because I know Trump
constantly touts operation warp speed
and he held the covid-19 vaccine is one
of the greatest achievements of mankind
do you agree with him on that
yeah I I don't you know because of what
we know now I think at the time cutting
through that again you can't fathom that
let a guy like a faucy and the people
developing this would do so in a
nefarious way meaning like I get listen
I get it I'm a capitalist I understand
profit motive I understand this that the
other yada yada but like it's people's
lives
um you know I think it took all all of
that time and all of those years to
fully just understand how bad it
actually is
um you know again it's easy to be a
Monday Morning Quarterback and say I
would have done it differently but
through it all the people that are
saying that now you see you look at
their social views I'm like oh really it
sounds like you were playing the exact
same game it's easy to say you would
have done it differently because there's
no way to prove and otherwise but like
your actions at the time it's not like
you called him out no one was doing that
because the media would destroy you
they'd but they'd literally be out there
and say you're you're killing Americans
you're doing this it's you're literally
costing tens of thousands I want to add
to the the the the context of the time
hindsight is 20 20. back when this is
all going on Trump was being cheered for
all of this like this is great good job
we want to see more of it in the early
days the conservatives were in favor of
masks then it flips fauci was saying
don't wear masks so like I think a lot
of what happens when we talk about the
Trump Administration and the past is
it's easy to look now based on all the
facts we have and say that is a bad
decision but I'll put it this way well
the other example and you know it's a
negative to us well I'll give it to you
would be like people's like well you
know the January 6th you know why didn't
you do anything I was like you mean in
the 10 days between January 6th and when
he left office when every TV Camera was
saying it was an Insurrection no one
really knew they didn't show the videos
that we haven't seen until basically two
weeks ago what was really going on like
he was supposed to blanket part and
everyone like I'm like I don't know like
we were told that that was really there
how do you do that now it's easy to say
it now yeah we we've seen the video we
saw the nonsense we saw the refusal even
a few weeks later but in that 10-day
period with literally the entire world
being like it was an answer
maybe you had to say well it was the
first unarmed Insurrection in literally
the history of the world which is
probably unusual but like given the
response like so I get it I wanna I
wanna I think ask you wrong but I but I
think I can think it's wrong knowing
what I know now at the time I'm like
holy I don't know like I you know I
thought it was probably overblown but
it wasn't so simple right I wanna I
wanna I wanna talk about 2024 and I want
to just say something real quick on on
DeSantis about a year ago I went on a
daily wire stream and said I was
probably leaning towards DeSantis as it
comes 2024 because he's done such
tremendously good things with with his
leadership in Florida and then as as
time's gone on more importantly as uh as
uh Donald Trump senior has come out with
messaging has started to focus on on
policy and the election it's been a
tremendous Improvement the East
Palestine thing where he shows up he
does the McDonald's thing that that
really does hit hard for me when he's
like I know the menu better than you and
he's buying people McDonald's I love it
I absolutely love it it gives me good
feels and I'm like I like seeing this I
don't see it from anybody else who's
running I like Vivek ramaswamy he didn't
go down there Marin Williams Williamson
seems very nice she didn't go down there
and so especially now with the
indictment I feel like Rhonda Santa
saying we will not be involved is a half
measure he should absolutely say you
will not extradite Donald Trump well
beyond that like that but that's like
that's the second part of it right that
was that's the response this week which
is a half measure last week was much
worse than that which is like Claire
it's a sideshow that's not real you know
it's it's made up like you mean it's a
sideshow that you've weaponized you know
the the government against its citizens
against its political oppositions yeah
oh that's a side show you know in
stalinist Russia uh you know that like
if you couldn't no no seriously if you
couldn't pick that out and I understand
just like the flip-flop on Ukraine that
he did as well like you know I get it he
he is you know he's been a career
politician he's beholden to his donors
probably his Consultants but like man
like if you don't realize that is maybe
one of the the fundamental issues of our
time if you're a Republican or a
conservative if that's going on like you
think you know right now I get it the
media is doing whatever they can to
boost him because they're afraid of
trump and what Trump will do again to
the uni party like oh no that's
wonderful but Hey Ron like one day they
may come for you and you don't think
it's an issue
so like I want a deeper Republican bench
man I I I actually believe this stuff
like there's no reason for me to be as
vocal as I am in this I had a pretty
solid existence as a real estate
developer uh in New York City I could go
to the cool person party and I was
welcomed in with open arms and could do
whatever I wanted like uh that's
different now and I'm okay with that
because I want to leave my country to
like my children in a in a form that
they'd actually recognize let me let me
ask you about that can I can I you're
not there right now I want to ask you
about that to elaborate on that
um I think it's fair point when when
your dad's taxes finally get released we
learned that he loses a bunch of money
throughout his first term as president
and didn't take a salary and I think
that says a lot I mean you guys are a
very wealthy powerful family I know
celebrities who have when when your dad
was running in 2016 with all the
negative press who would be like well I
know the trumps they're actually really
nice and good people they're super
generous but but you know he's a racist
now I guess and I'm not going to vote
for him I I'm wondering like if you want
to elaborate on the transformation from
like you mentioned going to the Cool
Kids Club then deciding to get involved
in politics and now like the media's
gone nuts and they treat you like trash
yeah listen like I said it was
interesting you know I I it's a lot of
those people all of a sudden you're
right I'm like we're racist like dude we
had dinner last month like what do you
like what like I have your cell phone
number like
we party together like you know when I
was young I'm like so so you think now
like and by the way it's not like I ever
hit by politics I was I was always a
conservative I was a big gun guy I was a
competitive shooter you know so I I had
my you know had my good you know redneck
friends up on you know on the weekends a
lot but I could still be a fixture in
New York it wasn't as much my thing it
was much more like you know my sister
Ivanka like she was it wasn't a woman
you know socialite in New York that
didn't want her daughter to turn out
like Ivanka Trump and all of a sudden
she's like okay I'm gonna go support my
father and they actually didn't get
involved in a lot of the controversial
stuff but like you know what's so bad
for like you know women who work and
it's like oh she's a pariah I'm like so
it was probably harder for her in many
respects than maybe because I was like
okay fine if I don't get invited to the
cool person but I don't care I'll go
hang out with you know sort of my good
Blue Collar friends which it always
meant more to me anyway like that's
probably why Politics the transition
sort of as brutal as it was for me was
kind of easy because it's like well
that's I actually get to be who I
actually am much more
than
than when I was in business I sort of
had to five days a week put on the suit
and you know be be that guy I could do
it I can play the game I get it like it
is a game uh but you know there was a
Friday afternoon I'd escape and I'd be
in you know middle of nowhere
Pennsylvania or Upstate New York and at
my cabin and so you know it was a little
bit easier and it so it didn't bother me
as much because I I guess I just see it
for what it is but yeah like a lot of
those people and you know I'm a good
enough person that's like hey man even
if we're friends like I'm not gonna call
you out on these things I'm not going to
do all of that literally I'm publishing
a book for my father uh right now you
know all the publishing houses were so
liberal and so uh jaded it's called
letters to Trump because we're going
through some files and I'm like oh my
God like here's a letter from Alec
Baldwin kissing your ass like here's the
letter from like no no Chuck Schumer and
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton like
it's it's sort of I mean I see this file
like his assistant did a really good job
just keeping some of this stuff and I
was like oh my God because it just kills
you let me how how much nonsense is
involved and you know I started a
Publishing Company because all the
liberal publishing companies which is
all of them were canceling a lot of
conservative you know writers are
telling them well you can't say that
even if it's just mainstream
conservative thought because they wanted
to impose their power and if they're
writing that upfront check to an author
or whatever it may be they were doing
this I was like I wrote my second book
uh and it was during covet and so I was
like well I had the time at home I was
like we're going to self-publish this
and try to do it because I saw what the
publishing houses were doing to me and I
had a number one New York Times
bestseller with my first book and but
you start seeing the games being played
I'm like let's try it let's you know let
they all say build your own so I was
like let's build our own let me let me
ask you about uh no you know finish that
finish the thought no go ahead it's all
good but the general point if we had to
combat some of this stuff and uh we I've
tried you know in whichever way we can
just to make sure to have an equal front
because what people don't understand
they're like well you're you know it
feels like it's overwhelming I'm like
yeah it is because we're up against a
trillion dollar big Tech Enterprise that
is just radical left uh you know social
media other than maybe truth social uh
you know heavily heavily skewed uh to
the left just look at the way they
censor and you know and or fact check uh
you have mainstream media another
trillion dollar organization I mean we
are up against a juggernaut and like
we're still doing pretty good someone
someone in the chat asked about you and
your dad's stance on the Second
Amendment yeah
well listen I'm about I mean I shot
200 rounds today
like yeah as it gets I mean yeah I shot
competitively for many years I've you
know a gun collector I've spoken at
every major you know gun event out there
that uh you know my father's more of a
golfer he understands the Second
Amendment and you know I I'm not just
someone who believes in the Second
Amendment I'm actually you know uh an
Enthusiast unlike you know somebody of
the politicians even the conservative
politicians where you see them you know
they take their obligatory gun picture
and their fingers on the trigger and
they're pointing it in someone's face
and you're like you know dictating I
guess you you can believe in the Second
Amendment and not know how to actually
use a gun but you know it probably helps
to have some experience hey hey Don Phil
I want to hear uh I I want to go back to
something that ilyad had said he he
mentioned um what you what you thought
the the
um sorry about that
um I apologize for his partner Iliad was
a book by home he only has a good book I
apologize
um but one of the biggest things that my
problem with Donald Trump was was the
you know the swamp the bureaucracy do
you think that that's going to be the
the Prime Focus that if he gets elected
again is to really go in there and tear
it out because I think that that could
really get a lot of them all yeah a lot
of the libertarian people out there that
don't like you know a lot of the big
government stuff
um the New York style politics and stuff
the the Libertarians you got to remember
that and I get that I I I get that so I
mean I think you do have to do because I
don't think you have a choice right the
swamp's not you know if you if you go
easy on the swamp we've seen that no
they're not going to give you it was
like you know my lawyers after after the
stuff for Russia Russia Russia they're
like hey man there there they want to
try you for treason like you got to take
that seriously you can't be on social
media talking and fighting back
like they want to put you in jail for
life or you know or worse and I'm like
you don't understand like they're not
like if I curl up in a ball and suck my
thumb in the corner crying for mommy
like they're not gonna go any less
they're gonna go harder it's like when
when people do their apology tours and
it's I'm like oh that was a mistake
because a you weren't really wrong but
they're going to use your apology as the
validation for the fact that you
actually did something wrong in the
first place so you're trying to be a
decent human being by apologizing and
just saying hey fine will a degree to
disagree and that's that's just the
starting point for them canceling you
and so you know I think that New York
style politics like I think you need it
because that's what we're up against and
I also think you have again all things
are a little bit about perspective right
like
fine he was right he maybe got rougher
but like they got rougher because
they're trying to throw his family in
jail for nothing we know that like that
that's no fact they're trying to throw
him they impeached him twice for what
growing a great economy and this all
nonsense like you know you have to have
that hard approach if you go soft you
don't get points for going soft I'll
tell you what they don't they don't give
you like okay well fine we're gonna
we're gonna let Trump you know real for
a little bit more oil and gas and boost
the American economy because he's being
friendly and nice that's not how it
works they don't care if they had if
they if they had like a moderate
Democrat in 2016 and throughout 2020 who
was talking about helping the working
class securing our borders like things
Bernie Sanders had talked about in 2015
and they did not lie about literally
everything related to your dad I'd have
I'd have been like well you know I think
I'll still vote Democrat but they are
corrupt if they lied they manipulated
and they didn't care about our country
and so naturally for a while I'm like I
hate everybody then I saw the Trump
second term agenda and I said these are
actually things I've been complaining
about for a long time I'd be a hypocrite
if I didn't vote for it and I think it's
safe to say that President Trump hears
people's concerns these listens and now
he knows I think the first the test
trial for not you know for you guys the
first term you guys did incredibly great
things president Trump had a record
Academy he had energy and dependencies
brokering Middle Eastern peace he was
putting bringing jobs back to America
just wanted to gut the bureaucracy and
and that's the pro that's the part that
he didn't realize like we knew a swap
was there they knew a swap was there but
they didn't know how deep and now
everybody knows how deep and everybody
knows exactly what roles they are
exactly who needs to go I don't want to
belabor the point but yeah it sort of
like like I said earlier it's like now
that you've had that Insider perspective
like I realized like there's not even a
you know I've been a fly on the wall
I've been in the room and I see the
reporting about it like there's not a
pretense of like objectivity or a
pretensive you know trying to get the
truth out there it's it's just narrative
I think uh and I think everyone else has
seen that now as well I mean I I sort of
did the you know I did a tweet earlier
that went pretty good and it was like
you know it's it's weird like uh all the
people who visited Epstein Island like
no one's been indicted no one's there
English in Maxwell I guess is doing 25
of years of hard time for sex
trafficking minors to no one because
they're going to indict president Trump
with something that's never even been
tried as a felony for a camp a a made-up
campaign violence violation because the
federal government themselves decided it
wasn't real like that merits an
indictment and their obligatory purple
now I think they also turn them into an
absolute Legend uh when they do this
that's fine I'm okay with that but like
just think of the the juxtaposition I I
use the you know imagine Don Jr did one
of the 500
like degenerate things that Hunter Biden
did
like just one like I you know I
understand according to the left I'm not
the upstanding human being that Hunter
Biden is I'm a terrible guy but like I
don't know I imagine I did one of those
things whether and again I don't even
I'm not even talking about the money
stuff I'm talking about the hookers and
the crack and the you know and
videotaping all of it imagine what
Hunter decided it's like hey you know
this is a bit too much for video imagine
what else is out there and by the way
imagine how many of our enemies probably
know what else is out there and I wonder
if we're being played no no seriously
like it seems like everyone has a hunter
Biden laptop you don't think the Chinese
they give him one billion dollars do you
think the Chinese give a billion dollars
to your average crackhead no they don't
unless they're buying you I wanted to
say you think the Ukraine does the same
thing no I wanted so we're spending 130
billion in a country that we don't know
and no one's even bothering to ask hey
do you think our decision-making process
is Jaded by what they may have on on the
bidens like I know if it was Don Jr
they'd be asking the question I'd be in
jail I wanted to say on the point about
firing all the bureaucrats I actually I
believe that if if Donald Trump is
re-elected if he gets a second term in
the 2024 election and wins a large
portion of these people will quit resign
and they will run for the hills that
would be so Good by the way that would
be the greatest thing in the world to
happen and that's the reality if you had
eight years you have some of
more of most people's careers uh you got
to do that but yes I think if they
realize that someone's just going on
there and they don't care and they don't
have to get reelected and they don't
have to make friends and frankly they've
been treated so poorly that they don't
they don't care about any of that like I
I think literally like that's uh that's
what I'd be voting for I don't care
whoever if it was going on for someone
else and they were doing the same thing
to someone else you know some time down
the line I was like I'm voting for that
guy just because I want to see that
place just you know taken down to the
bones I do think that if if he wins
again I do believe he will a lot of
these people will quit out of protest
and the swamp will start dreading itself
fear so there's another fear and call it
a protests absolutely but you know after
the 2020 election there was a moment in
time where a guy named Jeffrey Clark was
almost appointed to be the attorney
general and you've had him on your show
yeah yeah and
hundreds of people at the Department of
Justice said if Jeffrey Clark becomes
the AG we'll quit and now we just have
to find out we found out exactly what we
need to do to get I don't know anything
about his politics but I'd be like hey
he's now number one or two on my list
yes they said they'll all quit so the
swamp would drain itself at the doj all
you have to do is point a point Jeff
Clark as AG so do we have a solution to
that one
um but you know all of these different
bureaucrats and all these different
agencies I think we got to move a lot of
these people out of Washington DC put
them in real America
um and they'll quit and protest out of
that as well but
um we're really looking forward to a
second trap term because you guys know
where the the bodies are buried you know
who needs to go and uh I don't think
that you're gonna hold any punches
because uh I think he has been treated
incredibly unfairly you know what the
metaphor I want I want is with it's like
Donald's Donald Trump hit your dad Don
senior is like on his knees and they're
like they're like being metaphorically
you know in the movie and he's like his
face is all bloody knees down he looks
up at the guy and looks him in the eyes
and he says you're pardoned
because that's the christ-like thing to
do I think it might not be the battle
strategy tactic but I think that that
will it'll just resonate you're on the
other side of this one I want him to go
in with a bunch of guys dude I want him
to go with federal law enforcement and
be like you're all under arrest yes
my perspective has changed because of
what I saw they tried to do to me like
literally you know I had you know Adam
Schiff and you know some of those guys
like on TV every I committed treason
like I'm a patriotic American man I take
that seriously you know beyond the
fact that it's you know a crime
punishable by death like you're just
saying like I'm I'm not Amer Adam shifts
in America like give me a break like uh
I you know so yeah I'm coming at it from
a much more uh pissed off perspective
um but you know again you look at just
what's going on you look at the
decisions you look at the prioritization
you look at the sound bite everything
that's coming it is a clown show do you
think that we could like clown show you
listen to the press secretary and it's
like you know and I I I got all sorts of
hell look at John fetterman you know
Pennsylvania you know senator they
they've called me I'm every name in the
I'm an ableist apparently I discriminate
against people with disabilities because
I've been like you know calling him out
for not being able to complete a thought
or a sentence and then he's and I'm like
I don't think it's an unreasonable
expectation guys not for a senator no
for an American to assume that his
Senator a person making trillion dollar
decisions perhaps life and death
decision sending our kids to war
especially when dividing the
administration is saying we're the
closest we've been since the 1960s in
the Cuban Missile Crisis like I don't
think it's an unreasonable thing for me
to expect a United States Senator to
have basic cognitive function and if you
look at that guy that's like the minimum
standard that's why he's been in a
hospital for a month you spend more time
in a hospital but they knew that when
they ran him in a primary but he was the
most radical so they let him get through
it they're saying oh you're a terrible
person for doing this he's stressed out
already he was stressed out before and
you ran him for Senate okay like I'm not
the bad guy here folks you can say what
you want I'm not gonna apologize I'm not
gonna withdraw my comment Siri I think
it'd be wonderful if he was a bad guy at
Walmart that's one great gainful
employment is important everyone should
have it John fetterman has no business
being a United States Senator exactly
done it doesn't take a brilliant person
to figure this out but oh man they went
after me I'm the most discriminatory
person in the world for expecting the
guy to be able to you know
I want to ask you about this we have
this story from the post-millennial uh
New York City Jerry found Douglas Mackey
guilty in first ever meme trial after
making memes that disparaged Hillary
Clinton in the 2016 election I have the
tweet it was this uh that would be my
first party man that guy that was Ricky
Vaughn right well but he's one of the
great like the original yeah like sort
of Twitter accounts like manga accounts
I mean think about we live in a country
right now this is the United States of
America where they want to put a guy for
a meme in jail for 10 years not
one they're gonna
Yeah well yeah yeah you're right they've
already lost the trial theoretic like
like that would be my first pardon
because but it's it's state level you
can't pardon him like that's think of
the things that think of the thing well
you're right I guess but think of the
things that though degenerate left puts
out there and not a consequence no one
ever goes after they don't even get fact
checked I mean I look at some of the
stuff they say about me I'm like well
these are demonstrably false and they're
like yeah wow we can't we can't look at
that let's go but you fact check me when
I say this is my opinion and you you
come up with some sort of arbitrary way
to say well that's fact I'm like I'm not
allowed to have an opinion well so we
also have this tweet from Christina Wong
where on uh November uh November 8th
2016 she did almost the exact same thing
tweeting out for Trump supporters to
text in their vote she didn't include a
number but she even included super
Wednesday a fake day for voting and
she's not been charged so I see this
story as a perfect example of
partnership that's how it works there's
not there's no equal justice under our
law anymore we have a two-tiered system
okay whether it's Christina Wong versus
the Ricky Vaughn whether it's Hunter
Biden versus me you know it can't be
more apparent and again it's not like
it's just anomalous they only go one way
politically only one way politically
there's not even I can't even come up
with examples of the left on this and
again whether that's censorship whether
that's actual prosecution uh the list
goes on and on it's it's so stacked did
you we have to understand that and we
have to all be engaged in it because
otherwise it's over did you know that
the Marshall's outside of the uh Supreme
Court Justices homes were ordered not to
arrest the protesters unless absolutely
necessary despite the fact the protests
are actually illegal
yeah and and if we did that to Ruth
Bader Ginsburg before she passed they'd
all been in there with the January 6th
prisoners
how many people were arrested Tim uh you
know in the summer of love you know in
the 2020 you know billions and billions
of dollars of damage people murdered
David Doran and others uh buildings
burnt to the ground arson yeah you can
you can loot a Gucci store and you know
steal it works because you know it's in
the name of social justice you ready for
this one you ready for this one how many
were arrested this one actually this
this is important
there were 19 plus deaths and 14 000
arrests now it may sound like well then
there these people are being held
accountable right you mean if somebody
were let go right away not only were
most of them probably let go but don't
you think 14
000 plus arrests over a period of two
weeks should be the major story of the
past few years like yeah 14
000 people were arrested
they were mostly peaceful oh right right
two billion dollars I was watching a
reporter say that live because I was
like man this is crazy I don't want he
goes it's mostly peaceful I go dude
there's a building burning in the
background and like three seconds later
the reporter got hit in the head with
like a brick yeah I'm like but but they
went to like don't believe you're a
lying eyes you can see it it's happening
in real time yeah but to your point
we're trying to do to Kyle Rittenhouse
like oh God lunacy well to your point
about the folks you know getting
arrested and being let go right away I
mean there's a great deal of people that
that fall into that bucket but like just
a total prosecution number of those
people are like 50 60 January 6th
defendants in Washington DC there's a 99
conviction rate 99 of course because
because you can't there's there's you
can't find an impartial jury in
Washington DC they know that it's what
they're doing with Trump in New York
you're not gonna find you know people in
a a jury that aren't going to convict
Trump yeah you don't have people that
believe uh you know that he's got to
write a fair trial they're fine saying
ah you know we're they're really for
democracy when they can make up some
sort of sound bite against it but if
they can use it to weaponize against
someone else who doesn't share their
exact opinion we've seen this this is
how the left has functioned as they've
sort of devolved into you know
full-blown you know stalinist you know
type mentalities uh you know look at
what they've done to like Martina
Navratilova right uh oh yeah incredible
tennis player one of the leaders of the
you know the gay and lesbian movement
she was preaching for that movement and
fighting for that movement 30 years
before it became All the Rage way before
it was cool but then when she came out a
couple years ago and was like well I
don't think men should be like competing
against women in sports like I was one
of the elite women athletes of all time
and like the men would have destroyed me
they canceled her 30 years of activism
just for having a different opinion
total and complete surrender we again
we've I hit it earlier in the talk but
like uh you know we saw that this
weekend you know it it we really should
be you know praying for the trans
Community because they're at risk I'm
like what
we're getting minerals genocide I'm like
but where like I haven't I haven't heard
anything what are you talking about like
yeah I'm committing genocide by saying I
don't believe a three-year-old uh it
should be given puberty blockers in
forced uh into something by a teacher
without parent parents being involved I
don't think I think they should have
liability to the doctors when that kid
turns of legal age the recidivism rate
is like 94 if that kid turns of age and
is not happy anymore they should be able
to sue the teacher I got the doctor
their parents anyone else who was
involved in this decision-making process
because that kid couldn't buy a pack of
cigarettes for 15 years but we're gonna
give a
life-altering body altering meds rugs
and hormones and that make to be against
that makes makes me you know a committer
of Genesis it's stupid I want to ask you
two more questions one one uh uh one of
them will be a bit simpler but the first
one is we're getting a lot of people
asking about your views on Julian
Assange and whether or not he should be
pardoned
yeah you know that's it's a really
interesting question uh Assange uh
listen I I years ago when it first
started happening I would have said no
now I'm like oh my God like he's he was
on this stuff you know again years ago I
was like all right you know him um the
other guy who gave up the military
secrets with uh
Edward Snowden
Snowden yeah yeah you know I would have
been like I would have taken the No No
that briefly a hundred percent
a hundred percent you got to let those
guys out because they actually caught us
doing all the things we said we weren't
gonna do wow they caught us in the lie
and like it's out there like
and now I've seen what what's actually
going on again my world view uh the
America I believed or wanted to believe
existed like that doesn't exist anymore
guys it and every day that's further and
further gone we just are being more and
more awakened to the reality of the
situation it's not that it's getting
worse it's probably been really bad for
a long period of time we just now know
it and we're seeing it with our own eyes
I don't think so yeah I don't think that
was it that's an easy question to answer
but there were a lot of people I think
my mind has my mind has changed on that
a lot when even when we first got into
politics I'd have been like no that's a
bad thing we can't have that but I'm
like now everybody's cheering now that
they're like yeah yeah so you're right
we got I got one more question though
because I we're going to jump over to
this Andrew Tate story but while we have
you uh the the next question that
everyone seems to be asking is how how
and when can we get your dad on the show
and you I mean have you actually come in
the studio to be honest
honestly if I can do anything to avoid
going into DC I usually will but but uh
I'll take it up there and coming there
I'll I'll talk to him about that and by
the way I guess you made another example
right like I need someone you know I
I've hung out with I've you know going
back and forth like he feels he's been
in jail like I don't even know they
haven't even told us what he's done he
didn't charge he's not charged with
anything
on his behalf it's crazy I mean it's an
example of what this country could
become if we let go of our constitution
well but it but it sort of has right
like like he was when I spoke to him you
know last I was like hey man come on you
know if you come to the states I'm not
going to the states they'll put me in
jail I'm like States will you know I
don't think like legitimately I don't
think that oh sorry to interrupt you
there oh no no no worries um I don't
think that it's that it's bad that it's
really I mean it is obviously it's not
that it's getting worse it's that we're
seeing how bad it is and we have an
opportunity to make it better like it's
been bad for a long time we're just like
every day we're like oh here's another
example of how bad it is uh you know a
guy like that he's held without whatever
I don't know like if you're doing what
he's doing it's and it's hard right it's
hard for me like the Flynn example I
used earlier like well like well if he's
trafficking women like well maybe I
gotta stay silent maybe I gotta you know
you can't you can't come out against
that it's like yo I'm a very strong
believer that that's terrible and
but that's what they do but then you
know nothing happens they can put you
away for six months like well why are
they going after him to begin with oh
because he's actually influencing a lot
of young males uh talking about you know
masculinity being okay and not not
necessarily the four-letter word that
it's made out to be oh God forbid you
have you know high tea you know you're
not a soy uh kid walking around with it
like I don't know like it seems odd it
seems that anyone that speaks out
against that system even a little bit uh
or or would encourage a large group of
people to not just buy into it you know
they're just singled out and and
isolated and effectively taken out again
if he did something that's terrible I
don't I don't condone it but man it
seems like you couldn't put someone in
jail for a few months not show anything
and expect us to believe it's actually
real right like we should be cynical
based on virtually everything we've seen
uh in the world for the last six years
and you know maybe that's the greatest
thing the greatest Legacy of Trump would
be that he actually the Trump
derangement syndrome that ensued uh
uh showed us all of these things that we
probably would not have seen otherwise
we're going to jump over to covering
that story but uh I gotta say dude
seriously thank you so much for coming
on as long as you did I thought we were
going to get you for a couple minutes we
had you on for like it's been almost
like an hour so bro uh thanks for
hanging out all right sorry to cut in on
Alexa but you know no way you're still
my Thunderman I'm trying to get famous
over here yeah hey guys the reality like
I said I it'd be easy to shut up and be
a real estate guy in New York you know
we got plenty of good assets like like I
actually I believe this stuff like it it
means something to me I like I you know
I don't do it lightly it's not a it's
not an act or shtick like we got to do
something about it and uh you know I
I've I've had I guess a blessing of
having my eyes open to what's really
going on and I got to make sure that
other people see that right on man well
thanks for joining us for as long as you
did and uh we'll connect we'll figure
out a time we can get you out here and I
appreciate it thanks for coming on and
thanks guys have a good one
be good
I I'm I'm totally down to just like sit
back and have him take over but we're
like eight minutes from Super chats and
I do want to make sure we we show the
agitate stuff because this is big I know
what he's saying about feeling forced to
serve like it's so easy just to sit back
and make money in this doing this job
what we do just talk about it from a
distance but at some point you got to
serve your country well I don't want to
waste too much time on this but I just
want to say just uh you know I got I've
got to know Don very well over the last
you know couple years here and I think
he's such an awesome guy who has gone
through hell 50 hours of testimony out
of ship one to imprison this guy and uh
you know I thought after the election he
could you know he would have just kind
of packed it up and wanted to relax a
little bit but he got straight to work
and one of the big projects that he's
been working on is building up the
parallel economy fighting back in Smoke
America you know he's involved with a
company called Public Square uh that I
know that you guys know for the show but
but Don is helping spearhead that
company trying to take that company
public in quarter three identifying
hundreds of thousands of businesses that
share our values that's how we fight
back he has his Buck Publishing Company
because all these companies are
canceling folks he he's involved with
the new hiring board called red balloon
like Don is building up the parallel
economy as we speak right now it's
incredible work let's jump to the story
about Andrew Tate because we've got this
breaking footage Benny Johnson posted at
breaking news Andrew Tate and Tristan
are freed from prison and so here we can
see they're just they're coming out
unshaven and then we have this other
video that people were mentioning Andrew
Tate tweets since last year I've been in
24-hour lockdown no yard time pacing a
three meter cell with zero Electronics
or outside contact absolute Clarity of
Mind real thoughts real plans Vivid pain
one hour home and I can't stand my phone
some habits die hard we must defeat
shaytan and then people are pointing out
that he was he was not sitting around
doing nothing he was he was working out
when he was eating nice he is a member
of the clean play club that man has been
eating a lot of food and doing a lot of
push-ups I would love to talk to Andrew
if you're out there Andrew so he's on
house arrest now he's interested have
been moved from the jail cell to house
arrest
yeah so I think we got to hear from The
Daily Mail they say freed Andrew take
claimed he is now absolute Clarity of
thought an ecstatic tank etc etc they
walked into the Bucharest jail together
uh let's see uh uh where is the they
they like putting all this puff stuff in
here at least I left her money in jail
can you give me the news on what what
this is all about it's hard to pull it
up when it's like the last minute but uh
well there you go the bail application
was rejected on Wednesday all four
appealed the decision today the court of
appeal in Bucharest ruled that the
brothers and two alleged accomplices
would be released from prison a place
under house arrest a spokesman for the
Tate Brothers exclusively told
mailonline were ecstatic to announce the
Romanian Judicial System approved Andrew
and Tristan Tate's appeal against last
week's extension uh decision they will
be placed under house arrest while the
investigation continues so my
understanding is still they've never
been charged with any crimes and they
have women who have come out and
testified
in their defense and a judge ruled now
you're brainwashed so to see him be
released it's crazy I said good I
tweeted and these lefties are like oh
but haven't you seen the things he said
I'm like dude
he could have said the worst thing in
the world he could have said the worst
things in the world he could have gone
on the most vile Rants and what would I
have to say about that wow I really
don't like those guys opinions however
he wasn't charged with any crime so why
are they locking him up I get it it's
Romania okay so it's not the United
States but my moral standard regardless
of the law is don't lock people in boxes
that you have no evidence of wrongdoing
they're not even accusing of wrongdoing
100 you know I wasn't even a follower of
Andrew tase I didn't know much about him
until all this happened and the day he
got arrested I was hanging out with my
my friend Eddie and uh you know Eddie's
just your your typical 20 some year old
dude he's like I love Andrew Tate this
guy speaks the truth the guy did nothing
wrong I'm like dude how do you know for
a fact he's like he did nothing wrong
and so I started looking into the case
because of uh Eddie and
um then he had the alleged victims his
abuse victims that said I wasn't abused
at all like Andrew did nothing wrong and
Tristan did nothing wrong and it's just
another example of persecution of
anybody that that questions the regime
and did somebody in the United States
state department make a phone call to
Romania and encourage them to take care
of the Andrew Tate problem because he's
becoming too influential in America you
never know and we don't have too much
faith in the actors at the state
department when in our government to
make when two women come out and say
we're accused of being victims but we
will testify under oath this is not true
and a judge says don't care I'm like
some fish is going on at least get a
psychoval on the girls no no no like if
you don't believe them I can respect
that but we don't psych eval Witnesses
exculpatory Witnesses not in the U.S we
don't and I think that that should apply
everywhere and I know Roman is different
I know it's their own law but my
standard is not based on legality it's a
moral standard of yo come on what though
you're brainwashed you don't count like
two women with adult human brains have
told you they're not victims that's it
well on January 6 president Trump said
peacefully and patriotically protest and
then you know people disregarded what he
said in his actual speech and then they
said he incited Violence by saying those
words so like the the regime doesn't
really care they make up and they
try to throw anybody that they deem a
threat in jail you know I watched a
Tucker Carlson tonight uh interview with
Tucker and Andrew Tate and you know
everybody said Andrew Tates the
misogynist he's crazy he's this he's
that and I listened and he's very
articulate he's well spoken and he has
convictions and
um you know they're just throwing him in
jail because his message is resonating
with others and it sounds like another
guy I know they it's it's kind of poetic
that the day they let out one guy that
questions the regime and and the regime
hates they try to arrest another so and
they they also let Jacob chancelly out
yesterday or the day before he's the the
Q Shaman from January 6th there was
evidence came out that Tucker Carlson
showed the video of two weeks ago or so
but but now he's out but his release was
scheduled oh and so as large like no no
this was his normal time to be at least
nine months earlier so like to like a
halfway house or something thing like
that and then what was it he tweeted or
something he tweeted yesterday I always
saw I saw it in my feed it had 16 000
likes or something and then my feed like
Auto refreshed which is a big problem on
Twitter you guys got to fix that yeah
and it disappeared in his channel I
can't find his channel real real quick
someone super chatted Matt says to go to
New York City a lot are you gonna you're
gonna go up to New York on Tuesday when
Trump's supposed to be indicted yeah
I'll be there yeah let's let's get it
let's let's let's figure it out anyway
let's go back to what we were talking
about I was just excited by that I'm
like oh man we definitely got to have
you up there I don't know while we're
talking about January 6 characters I
think one of the greatest characters
ever was the lectern guy oh yeah he was
on the show and I just realized he
follows me on Twitter so like they call
him Podium guy but it was a lectern so
it's like it's elected so at at lectern
leader on Twitter that guy's a goat for
real lectern leader and there's Adam
Johnson there was a situation where Ron
DeSantis was at a campaign event and
somebody took his Podium and he's crying
where's my Podium go where did I Podium
go and there was a meme of Lecter taking
away the podium I'm like this guy
awesome so
um lectern leader he served his time in
jail I don't think he should have ever
gone
um but you know lectern leader and the Q
Shaman Let My People Go Joe Biden
for sure man a mass pardon and I'm
talking about across the aisle no and
setting down tensions that's where you
lose me buddy squeezing tighter I don't
think that's how we win dude you don't
win by getting kicked in the face
repeatedly until you're on the ground
and go thanks buddy I forgive you well
that's how you win friends
those deal with it so on
January 6 I'm 23 years old I don't know
too much about anything I'm in
Washington DC for the protest I'm a
trump supporter I have questions about
the election
two years go by almost a year and a half
goes by don't hear from anybody all of a
sudden I get an email from you know I'm
like I feel bad I have a pit in my
stomach I feel bad for what's going on
to a lot of these January 6 protesters I
decide to make an announcement I'm going
to donate fifty thousand dollars to help
j6 political prisoners
two days after I make this pledge and it
goes public
I get an email from a guy named Sean
tanoli from the January 6th committee
Alex we believe you have information
related to January 6th and we would like
to speak with you
I go on Tucker Carlson the next couple
of days I tell him the F off in a nice
way they subpoena me I have no knowledge
about January 6. zero whatsoever they
subpoena me they forced me to spend tens
of thousands of dollars they dragged me
before the Congressional committee Adam
kinzinger is the only member that shows
up I'm wearing a subpoenaed hat because
I'm like
but they forced me a guy who's trying to
have a future have a family one day they
forced me to spend tens of thousands of
dollars to defend myself over
so when we get back power I don't really
want to have peace with these people who
did this to us and are continuing to do
this to us I think that we have to turn
the tables on them give them a dose of
their own medicine and then we can even
the playing field and then we can
discuss Unity they've got look people
who broke the law go to jail and the
issue is they're saying oh Donald Trump
in this this indictment blah blah blah
misdemeanor charge does not feel real
they have falsely accused Trump of being
a Russian spy one dude went on MSNBC and
said he worked for the Soviet Union that
Trump may have been an asset of the
Russian since the 80s which was the
Soviet Union and it's just like
you're insane this is not real you have
lost your minds so when they're doing
this I'm just like I don't care I don't
believe it they get no benefit of the
doubt from me but that what they're
doing is unprecedented now what we need
is I'll put it simply I will be
satisfied right now if Trump goes in and
schedule F fires everybody schedule F
right yep just fire them all and look
into that fire because I don't care I
don't care if they're criminals okay if
they're not we need term limits for
bureaucrats we can't have permanent
government actors because then you end
up with a permanent government well what
if he creates a law that creates term
limits for bureaucrats
what if he works with Congress to create
a law rather than firing people no he
creates a law that makes them their
careers terminated
clean them out and then clean out the
existing bureaucracy then if there's if
Congress wants to pass legislation
talking about uh term limits or
something I would I would endorse that
kind of stuff well but get rid of the
bad apples that are in there now and if
you get rid of some good app apples
getting rid of bad apples it's fine
you're not putting people in jail you're
not killing people you're just firing
people they'll go find jobs in some
other field hopefully whatever they
they're all probably millionaires
anyways or at least have plenty of money
they fire them all these bureaucrats
probably make decent money yeah and and
we should just it's not I'll put it this
way I'll meet you halfway in it's not
personal it's not punishment it's we
have to reset the permanent government
but what we don't want a permanent
government so we're going to terminate
these jobs we're going to set a new law
a new standard saying you can only work
for the government for x amount of years
then we're going to rehire from fresh to
to just clean house but what concerns me
is an Art of War metaphor is that
there's a large advancing enemy in front
of you you're like I don't like that
enemy everyone we're severely
outnumbered everyone Advance direct
attack on what we don't like like just
doing the brute straightforward thing is
not the way you win against this we're
not talking about violence though no I'm
talking about firing no it's a metaphor
of how you handle business yeah and and
so it's
other countries eliminate their entire
governments or at least don't tell them
you're going to do it before you do it
they're they're there are because then
they know it's
nothing it's gonna run on that he's got
to get elected on that and he has to
tell the American people that he's going
to do that it is better for him to say
hey look I'm telling the American people
this is what I'm running on then he gets
elected then he has a mandate from the
American people he can say to the
bureaucracy hey look the American people
elected me for the specific purpose of
firing all your asses like otherwise it
seems like a dictator going in gets
elected doesn't say that he's going to
change the government gets elected and
then comes in is like everyone's fired
and then everyone's gonna be like oh my
goodness he's a dictator they're going
to do that anyways but at the very least
if he says look I'm good this is what
I'm running on and he gets elected then
he's telling the electorate the
population knows what he's doing before
they vote they vote for him then he has
the ability to say look they knew what I
wanted I'm I was doing this they voted
for this we're going to go go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel become a member at timcast.com
because you can join our Discord you see
uh we have a super chat from DJ says is
Don Junior timcast first ever phone
guest well it was he's not because we
had uh who did we have Colin before on
the phone
James O'Keefe James O'Keefe called in
and we put the the the the phone right
up to the microphone but here's the
thing we've set up a members only
Discord server and that's how Don was
able to actually call in which means we
have finally set up a mechanism for
Collins however some people have said I
thought Tim said I'd never do Collins we
couldn't get video it was just a phone
call and considering it's Don Jr and he
wanted to talk about the indictment of
his dad and the breaking news I said
let's roll with it but I think a lot of
you can also notice it's hard to have a
dynamic conversation when someone's not
in the room so there's a lot that Don
needed to say that I respect and was
glad that he came out and said but what
we really need is for him to sit here so
there's like conversations in person are
dramatically different there's social
cues there's you know there's there's
pushback there's oh let me let me you
know why don't you jump in things like
that
so special shout out to Alex bruceowitz
for making that happen yeah absolutely
dude you know Kimberly was on a couple
of days ago and you know he was like I'm
not on the show yeah Don's great man
you're going to want to have this guy in
the show and he's going to make it
happen he's going to come out here and
he's going to hang out with you guys
shoot some guns with you guys yeah Don
let's shoot guns I'm I'm a big gun fan
myself we gotta we gotta we got a range
nearby with like a thousands there's
some political folks that run from
interviews right they have to have the
scripted interview they need to say this
is what we're discussing like uh I've
known Don long enough and I've seen
these guys in action these guys are
willing to take they believe in what you
know they actually believes in something
and they're willing to talk to talk
about anybody so when you become a
member you can join the Discord members
only and uh be in there when we have
people show up and and jump in the live
chat and things like that and also go to
castbrew.com and buy our coffee yep we
sponsored ourselves uh we are producing
our own coffee we're building our own
coffee shop and then shops because uh we
want to create physical locations and we
want to create products and we want to
expand the biz business and we want a
parallel economy we want companies to
exist that believe in American values
and meritocracy and individual
responsibility Etc all right here we go
Freedom Jeffrey says MTG is planning on
protesting in New York City on Tuesday
when Trump is turning himself in do you
think it is safe for me to live stream
it I don't know I don't know if he'll be
be safe
um
when I I'll tell you this because I
can't give you advice on Safety and
Security
uh there are dangers that come with you
know police and protests and things like
that I have no idea what's going to
happen in New York but I am not
let me just say I I'm somewhat concerned
about the potential for escalation
because peace peace Trump supporters are
probably going to show up and far
leftists will be in New York where they
live be very peaceful because I think
Alex you mentioned this earlier a mug
shot of Donald or an nft of a mug shot
is one of the greatest things for his
campaign this is not a time to get
nervous t-shirts can you imagine what an
nft of Donald Trump's mugshot like the
only nft
shot we've got uh what is this from
event University young Republicans are
hosting a rally on Tuesday with Marjorie
Taylor green
um in New York City look I think being
peaceful is obviously we should we
should see if we can get you connected
to film with them when they're setting
up we'll we'll make that happen yeah but
um you know I saw a lot of conservatives
when when this first broke saying you
know president Trump called for protest
and there's a lot of ways to protest you
can tweet you can you know uh talk to
people you can you know raise your voice
but you can also assemble and the
Democrats they use January 6 basically
as a tactic to scare conservatives from
protesting this corrupt regime our
country is going to hell right now
there's a lot to be upset about
and it's an American right to be able to
assemble peacefully and make your voices
heard and I don't think that
conservatives should be fearful of doing
that but I think people should learn
from what took place on January 6 they
should be vigilant they should be smart
they should be filming and they should
stay away from people that look like Ray
apps all right I said let's read some we
should Pro in the United States we need
to make protesting legal and one of the
greatest quotes I've ever heard my life
from Tim was a long time ago he went
America is a protest I was like oh yeah
it's true all right it's a 24 7 protest
against monarchy oh snap it's Dave says
Andrew take free if true get him on bro
well he's on house arrest
um I would I would love to do some kind
of interview with him and I think we
mentioned this before we were talking
with with Andrew Tate about doing a
profile or an interview literally like
two days before they arrested him and it
was the weirdest thing ever because we
were just like hey you know we were
trying to work out if we could send
someone out to go sit down with them and
and like break down who he is what he's
actually working on and you know he was
pointing out it's like it's a lot of
hard work it's grinding all day it's
probably boring and we're like that's
what people need to understand that they
see these these clips on the internet
and they think the the clip he makes
where he's doing this quick you know
pitch is is all of it when he's
literally telling people all the time
it's a lot of boring hard work and
grinding that you need to do so um maybe
I mean look the last thing I'm going to
do is be like now that you're out give
us the exclusive or whatever but uh you
know I'll we'll try and figure something
out I want to make sure we're being
respectful because the dude was just got
after several months I'm sure he just
wants to have a nice meal and then relax
a little bit maybe watch some TV and be
with his loved ones I can only imagine
how much he's changed after being in
solitary like he said that
I've never experienced anything even
remotely like that no I mean long-term
solitary confinement like it's insane
there's this idea that some you know in
solitary confinement you do something
bad you go get go in there for 24 hours
and they let you out you know I've got
to know a lot of these January 6
political prisoners families these
people are going in long-term solitary
confinement 15 20 25 days sitting there
in the dark on the ground you know it
can't talk to anybody can't see anything
and these are people who are charged for
misdemeanors for for tail and that's
pre-trial solitary confinement that's
what was happening in the DC jail and so
uh you know I feel terrible for for
Andrew Tay I feel terrible for these
people who are being so you know treated
incredibly unfairly all right let's read
this we got Raymond g Stanley Jr he says
Tim I have an idea I definitely didn't
see it on culture War today to spread
the having of chickens idea how about
selling Roberto Jr eggs and folks can
raise their own chicken City chickens so
we've actually been planning that
chicken in City brand chickens so so I
don't the issue is what are the
restrictions on selling on mailing eggs
but the idea was to actually mail like
four eggs to various members that are
interested in having chickens and then
you incubate them and then you will have
the chicken City Chicken genetics
so I got news Roberto Jr is getting to
uh he's about to age out of uh we're
going to do we're gonna do one I think
Roberto James got a couple kids already
we're gonna do a batch of a bunch of
Roberto Jr kids and then after that
Roberto Jr is going to retire we got to
figure out Junior he's so we we love
Roberto his dad but his dad's a dick we
got him from a farm and it's just it is
what it is but Roberto Jr Allison and I
actually incubated Hatchet and raise in
our in in our house and on our own and
we took care everyone with a little tiny
baby so we we he's more like a pet to us
so I'm thinking Roberto Jr is gonna get
a bit more luxury treatment than Roberto
did but Roberto's got it good he's got
open pastures and he's with the boys so
he's having a good time he's a bus but
uh Roberto Jr we're gonna we're gonna
take special care of him but it's an
issue of once he once he has a wave of
babies we don't want him banging his
kids Roberto did that but it's a chicken
thing it's a Joe Biden thing to do yeah
but it is a chicken thing it's called
line breeding and you can do it once or
twice because chicken genetics are
different but we're not going to do that
we want to we we really do want to bring
in Isaac who is half Brahma half Rhode
Island red but he's massive and he might
hurt the hands because he's too big so
we're gonna figure it out little Luke is
all grown up love those silkies uh I
don't think people have seen little Luke
because he's got a domed skull and that
means if we put him out there he could
get pecked and die because it's a
special kind of chicken but uh yeah so
so he's he's fully grown he's in his own
little locked you know a little
compartment he's got a little living
space but uh he was named Luke I think
it was by Luke because he was blonde
with blonde parted hair and a big nose
and then Luke said he's got blonde hair
and a big nose like me and we were like
we're gonna call him little Luke so now
he's all grown up but anyway that's some
clever names are there well you're a
genius for having chickens with the cost
of eggs and we have too many
on your podcast didn't you yeah so uh I
went to her house a couple like like two
years ago in Tampa or in St Petersburg
and I walked try to open her gate and
all of a sudden chickens start walking
at me I'm like I don't know why do you
have chickens in your at your house in
in downtown St Petersburg Alex you need
chickens you have to grow your own eggs
and I'm like uh I don't know two years
later later Anna's a genius she has her
own eggs she's not paid 11.99 at the
grocery store and uh we need more
thinkers like her in Congress oh she's
an environmentalist too let's read
brilliant brilliant we got this from
Nick P he says as a Brazilian immigrant
first generation I'm all about Trump
been to Colombia and everything lived a
good life then a third world life now
middle class life I can tell you that US
legal immigrants want Trump back in we
don't want these woke cultists that's
what I saw when I was in Florida
as I mean but Florida is kind of obvious
because Venezuelans and Cubans flee
there and then they're like none of that
we don't want that anywhere here so
they're all about Trump yeah you know
president Trump did incredibly well in
2020 with the Cuban voters and Hispanic
floaters in Florida uh you know
Florida's been read for both terms for
Trump uh or for both campaigns and it's
it's had a republican governor for uh my
almost my entire life and so that that
states in play but these people escape
corrupt regimes in these you know
countries and they come to America they
want a better life especially those who
do you know come here legally they want
to to be able to provide for their kids
and and have a a good life and they're
watching the same that took
place in their countries happening here
and they're not going to stand for that
and so I think president Trump's going
to do incredibly well uh with minority
voters with legal immigrants uh and he's
going to win an incredible landslide in
2024. all right we got this from the
kellysel hi Tim and friend this is the
third birthday I've donated so hopefully
you read it this year I've watched the
show dang near every night and thought
it was important to let you know
seriously thank you so much really do
appreciate it and you share birthday
with Kellen the best day of the year
happy birthday it's a good birthday
happy birthday and you're lucky it
wasn't one day later
yeah yeah there's this kid I grew up
with uh she had a birthday on April 1st
and I'd always that's how I remembered
because I'm like you're a joke and it's
the day after mine I was kind of bummed
that April 1st on a Saturday because it
meant that we couldn't get Michael
malice out here
um yeah what did he do last time he
slowly turned into Superman is that what
it was to take off his suit
and then whenever the camera would
switch a piece of clothing would be
removed and switch back he would look
he'll be more dressed like Superman that
was a good one
I don't know if we were supposed to tell
people what the joke was and just let it
ride but it's been a year go watch the
episode it's great yeah
all right
Eldritch and Nader says like Ian
mentioned this that's an ominous
precedent of targeting previous
administrations using force of laws of
cudgel this BS threatens to destroy any
pretensive legitimacy in U.S politics
elections and the world stage djt is no
crook pray for him
well Ian's correct and they've uh
they've been pointing that out as well
um there's a piece in The Spectator that
says Joe Biden's gonna spend the rest of
his days
uh talk like what is it seeing his son
his only living son being a federal
prison I think it does set a precedent
but also that that's why I'm obsessed
with mass pardons because I think that
can quell the precedent and make people
you know realize that we're in this
together M says why should the SanDisk
be pro-trump when all Trump has done is
ridicule and mocked DeSantis
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's an in it's a it's a relationship
it's Trump marks the status because
DeSantis is not supportive of trump and
and back and forth and because DeSantis
starts courting traditional neocon
advisors Trump sees him as potentially
wanting to run against him for his
re-election and then says who's this guy
like I support him and so I'm not here's
my thing Trump is doing a bad job of
going after DeSantis in my opinion I
think he could do a much better job
DeSantis is doing a very bad job of
appearing strong in the face of the
process of the persecution prosecution
and Trump's statements so I'm a little
disappointed with all of it but I think
ultimately DeSantis is in the weaker
position on this one and probably needs
to be playing smarter if he wants to
compete with Trump I don't think
DeSantis is getting it done right well
simply look I was very supportive of
Governor DeSantis especially when I
believed him to be a trump Ally uh you
know in 2018 he campaigned on President
Trump's message he piggybacked off of
trump to win the governorship uh and he
you know was was a decent Ally through
the remaining two years of the the Trump
presidency the first term and you know
and I was very supportive of him I get
called out for this all the time because
you know if you guys follow me on
Twitter some of you might
um you you'd recognize that I am very
aggressive in my messaging towards
DeSantis and team DeSantis what do they
do well they screenshots tweets screen
screenshot tweets of mine from 2021
praising him for something and I
absolutely did support him as Governor
but they can't find a tweet of mine from
2022 in support of him because in
January of 2022 we started paying
attention and got wind that he was
building up the shadow campaign against
President Trump he brought in new
advisors he brought new and so this you
know Trump first mentioned a negative
thing about him in right November but
there was this you know a lot of people
aren't paying attention to this level of
detail but we knew in 2022 that pre that
DeSantis was mounting a campaign against
Trump but DeSantis has done a very bad
job of actually playing playing the game
right I'll put it I'll put it simply the
first thing I said about this was
DeSantis should be deferential to Trump
every step of the way his only play is
you know Trump's the best president I've
seen in in my lifetime he is an
inspiration to me his endorsement got me
where I am today and I think it's better
for the American people to hear more
voices on stage if the American people
say Donald Trump is the guy then then
you know what they're right but if I was
saying this I would say what I want to
do is I want to be on that stage and I
want to speak with the American people
and Donald Trump and I want to give them
an opportunity and if they choose Trump
then that's then so be it but let's
let's give America as many choices he's
not doing that he's like he's he's
playing the C minus level game that
actually just comes off as more sneaky
and like bro we know what you're doing
we know you're running you know what I
mean like be honest give us a reason
give Trump the praise and credit he
deserves give him the criticism he
deserves and you'll come out looking
better instead it just looks more smarmy
than anything exactly and we had you
know Dom was on here early earlier you
know how many rallies that Don Jr did
for Rhonda said his 2018 and they're a
similar age
Don Jr went out of his way to help this
guy and we all wanted to help this guy
we all supported this guy and Don said
earlier we we wanted to have a
republican bench and I think everybody
in this room thought you know at least
if you're a Republican and if you're in
the Super Chat you're Republican a lot
of people thought Trump 24 DeSantis 28
but the Consultants would never let that
happen because the Consulting class
didn't get rich under President Trump
the Karl roves of the world didn't make
money under Trump but the problem that
the Santos is running into right now is
that he is no longer working with the
mega people that got into where he was
today he he is now working with the
folks the Karl roves the bushes The
Establishment Consulting class that
hasn't won the presidency since 2004.
these guys don't know the new Republican
party they don't know and they're
ruining this guy's career and it's
disappointing to see I I agree I think
if if Iran came out praising Trump and
said all I can say is I do want to run
and I will be on stage with Donald Trump
and if you think he's the right guy for
the job then you are correct hear what I
have to say and then there'd be nothing
to say against him other than like okay
well let's let's have a broad
conversation instead it's like Karl Rove
Jeb Bush like this Playbook doesn't work
and it's making him look C minus but I
want to go in circle serving the office
you want the best person in the role
even if it's not you I like him I think
he's a great governor and I think he
would also be a very good president but
I feel like it's very C minus play but
uh let's read this one uh where are we
at Kevin Harmon says if Tim Poole Don Jr
and Ben shapir had a conversation
together at full speed they would travel
back in time uh he's correct because
we've actually done it
um the three of us have been to the
Future and back is that where you got
the beanie not the beanie it's where we
got the jet pack you know the one you
were flying around on the other day yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah so we
actually went to the Future and then
came back is very easy thank you for
that thing by the way yes once we start
talking and then arguing it's the speed
increases as we attempt to talk over
each other faster and faster and faster
I texted you I texted you when you're
trying to ask Dad a question I said you
just gotta push through well the the
issue with that is he can't see our
faces right so he doesn't know what like
a lad or Phil or Ian wants to say
something there's digital interference
if you can only hear it over a digital
surface only one noise can get made at
the time so he so he only hears us when
when he pauses for a second because when
he's talking he's not gonna yeah like if
he's talking to his phone especially
which is what makes phone call shows on
podcasts very very difficult but it was
still awesome to have him come on and be
like hey the news broke it's huge news
talk to us I thought that was fantastic
all right let's see Phil dudbert says I
want to know what a lot is working on is
he going to be in New York reporting
we're definitely covering that rally on
Tuesday and uh yeah we got you we got
you right here connected huh absolutely
looking forward to covering it too
excited to happen there yep
all right let's uh let's grab where are
we at here also nice glasses a lot thank
you I like those guys Raymond g Stanley
Jr says Don Jr just earned himself the
spot is the third best Junior of course
the ranking is Roberto Jr then Raymond g
Stanley Jr then Don
Roberto Jr is my favorite Junior
that's just because he's my rooster is
that him behind you that's that's his
portion no that's just a chicken picture
I got somewhere
it was it was a chicken picture was on
sale and it's a nice picture
um we have a Weber Junior flag and we
are creating a new blend called Stand
Your grounds which was inspired by the
the members
and it's uh it's gonna be a medium roast
and the image is Roberto Jr
because we have a flag that it's it's
like a Gadsden flag but it's a rooster
you know standing up tall with its wings
out and it says stand your ground
and this is inspired by the fact that
roosters will sacrifice themselves to
save their hens
I find it very funny that the phrase the
word chicken implies cowardice when in
fact roosters which are chickens
literally run full speed to their death
to buy the hands only a few more moments
to escape which is like bro chickens are
brave man like the hens I get the ladies
are like run to cover and safety but
roosters are like a a tiny little
rooster will attack a full-grown human
being well if you think that feels
threatened well just to be clear
I make sure I walk on the
sidewalk on the right side of the
sidewalk so I would get hit by a car
first so basically I'm as tough as a
rooster well done look there are a lot
of human males in this country who would
not run full speed knowing they may die
if it meant saving the life of a child
and roosters do it a special shout out
to officers
exactly they had The Bravery of the
noble rooster you saw the guys running
up to the door and like the fear where
they pause the door and the guy on the
ground's like go and pushes him and they
go into what could be a hail of gunfire
uh neither and the chat says still no Mr
bocus blend there is going to be a Mr
bocus blend that is also in the works
we're gonna have four signature Blends
so we've got stand your grounds and the
next one's going to be what did I call
it
um I think I called it Mr Bump Mr boca's
pumpkin spice experience or something
like that but I don't know if they
actually if we can actually do pumpkin
spice yeah lots of yeah but that cat
would be a good a good flavor Mr Bogus
is not fat no no well he's getting fat
you should see him he's gaining weight
that's very good it's very good to hear
all right uh Russell Miller says looks
like Merriam-Webster Uh Oh YouTube just
jumped super chat's gone
well they said Miriam want to change the
definition of vengeance that didn't take
long
what really good take a look see if they
did
Tammy says Tim I so appreciate you not
doing this show by phone this sucks you
can hardly get a word in take a breath
Don Jr well I read that one just to
explain I don't blame the person on the
phone but this is why we don't like
doing digital calls because it's really
difficult to have a a working flowing
conversation when it's online and I get
a lot of people they're like well I do
tons of shows on like over Skype and
stuff like that and I'm just like
I get it and sometimes great ideas can
be conveyed on something it's not it's
not useful in some ways but what ends up
happening was I did I did Ben Shapiro
Sunday Special by we I recorded myself
on a camera while on a a low quality
stream and then had to mail him a memory
card this was back before we got the
internet installed and it was like Ben
would talk stop and wait and then I
would talk and then stop and wait
because it's like otherwise we know
we're just talking non-stop or talking
over each other at least here someone
can like put their hand up or someone
can just go no no no no no no and start
talking and then everyone starts yelling
and laughing and you know and your show
is a lot different setup than a lot of
these other shows like you have how many
people at this table right now and and
most people when they call in this
there's one other voice and I know so
your show's a unique setup for that Jeff
Bader gifted 50 memberships Tim guest
wow thank you very much I appreciate
that and everybody got the gift of
membership he asks what do you feed your
chickens well we feed them scraps but um
usually only fresh things that are
scraps like today we did a sushi order
for the company and then we took the
leftovers oh man you should have seen it
you throw in like a leaf or a flower and
the chickens will will run over and grab
it and eat it you throw in a small piece
of white tuna and those chickens go to
war they're like oh man it's the best
thing ever fortunately we had enough for
everybody everyone we got a little bit
Roberto Jr is too nice he he waits and
lets the hens eat all the fish and then
casually walks up and tries to take a
little bit it's crazy he would he would
kind of walk over a little bit grab a
bite and then let the hens just rip it
apart and then he would just stand up
and just wait and he's a rooster he's
bigger than all of them but that's the
thing he wants his ladies to be well fed
he knows it's less important for him to
have it more important for them to have
it yeah you don't want angry women all
right everybody if you uh one more
warmership chat Matt H says Tim you set
up a way for elite members to do
franchise a coffee shop that is in the
works this was suggested a while ago and
we definitely are going to do that so
uh oh Jeff gifted another 50 memberships
thanks man wow if you haven't already
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com and buy
our coffee at castbrew.com it's a
pre-order right now you can follow the
show at tickcast IRL you can follow me
at timcast Alex you want to shout
anything out uh I'd like to shout out
Douglas Mackey's defense fund meme
defensefund.com uh it's disgraceful that
Biden's trying to throw a meme maker in
prison so
um he needs money to fight and uh you
know file an appeal here so meme
defensefund.com
uh my name is alad eliyahu I'm a
journalist guys you can follow me on
Twitter at a lot of Yahoo and also be
sure to follow timcast news on Twitter
and I believe a bunch of other social
media platforms we have a lot of great
content there and that's where you get
to check out the news uh room's work and
Tuesday and Tuesday oh he's gonna be on
the ground tweeting from there doing
interviews as well so I'm excited for
that so check that out guys
I am Phil Lamonte lead singer of all the
remains I'm Phil that remains on Twitter
Philip remains official on Instagram and
uh yeah yeah Ian cross on uh pretty much
everywhere on social media Alex people
follow you to Alex Bruce Switz on
Twitter I know for sure and I wanted to
shout out Don's Publishing Company it
came a few times what's the name of that
company winning team publishing winning
team and the new book that comes out I
believe it's the last week of April it's
called letters to Trump and Richard
Nixon there's an awesome letter in there
from Richard Nixon writes to Rice to
Trump when you run you're gonna win and
uh you know that was back in the 70s and
Oprah's in there and Alec Baldwin all
these people you know when Trump
announced this book was coming out on
winning team publishing they're they're
all running to the media I don't mean
what I said about Trump 20 years ago
anymore I have I hate this guy now sure
I will like Oprah said he wanted to be
Trump's running mate if they ever ran
for president 2000 and then no not
anymore not anymore yeah not anymore
looking forward to that uh awesome well
Don thanks for coming on and uh everyone
else have a nice evening we also before
we finally jet have this dude with this
awesome headband thank you it's the
Maryland flag I know you Tim you started
like oh we hate Maryland but you know
it's my my home state so holds a special
place but hey uh good to see you again
Alex uh it was awesome talking about
Junior
follow me at Kellen PDL thanks guys
thank you happy birthday we have Clips
up throughout the weekend you can buy
cast brew coffee and we'll see you all
next time